j' très très vilain mon
père maises bien chers abonnés
pardonnez-moi car j'ai
pêché et j'anticipe déjà votre déception
voici l'instant
autopromotion la revue scepticisme
scientifique revue du comité para j'ai
publié un article qui s'appelle gevudant
des stats et des loups sur la bête du
gevudan nous ferons un live le 17
décembre sur la chaîne de scepticisme
scientifique la chaîne de Jean-Michel
abrassard venez nombreux c'est la fin de
l'instant autopromotion merci maintenant
il faut que je paye pour
[Rires]
ça c'est voilà je m'autorise très très
peu de placements produits mais là le
voilà cticisme scientifique il faut le
faire il faut le faire scepticisme
scientifique allez voir scepticisme
scientifique plein d'articles sceptiques
pour vous euh et maintenant bah c'est
l'heure de payer je me suis levé ce
matin en me disant j'allais faire un déb
cage et pénitence et j'ai voulu faire
une vidéo sur la cryptozologie en
rapport avec cet article jeevudans des
stats et des loups et puis en fait je me
suis rappelé qu'il y avait une autre
vidéo que j'avais réellement pas envie
de
faire parce que je rappelle les règles
de débunkage et pénitence la règle
numéro 1 faut que j'ai réellement pas
envie de le faire du tout faut que ce
soit un contenu que je nai pas du tout
du tout envie de voir ou de me faire
subir et il faut que ça ait quand même
plus de succès que ma chaîne histoire
que je fasse pas la promo de théorie
marginale enfin de théorie
conspirationniste blab blabla marginal
euh et vous avez été nombreux à
m'envoyer le cercle d'Ulfric et c'est
vrai qu'il a l'air d'un bon client le
cercle d'ulfrique parce qu'il y a quand
même pas mal de on vient d'Afrique
regardez cette miniature magnifique
c'est c'est quand même quelqu'un où on
retrouve bah voilà les civilisations
périssent parce qu'elles sont dégénérées
on on retrouve le mot arien cocasien
blanc un peu trop souvent pour que ce
soit euh pour que ce soit sain les
blancs mythiques de Nouvelle-Zélande le
premier empereur chinois était caucasien
et quand on explore un peu le cercle
d'Ulfric on se rend compte qu'il a une
autre chaîne sur odyssée et sur cette
chaîne on a carrément l'armée fr l'armée
française selon un racialiste blanc euh
qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autres combattre l'ennemi des valeurs
éternelles autant dire qu'on est face à
quelqu'un qui aime pas du tout la
théorie de l'évolution il aime pas du
tout du tout la théorie de l'évolution
parce que je pense hein à mon avis
n'est-ce pas
mes petits farfad des nationaux que
l'idée de partager un ancêtre en commun
avec les Africains ne lui plaît pas du
tout je pense je je je je c'est mon
c'est mon flaire c'est mon flaire iné
comme ça je j'ai des
intuitions et là ma petite intuition mon
petit doigt me dit
que il est pas content avec l'idée de la
théorie de l'évolution et donc il a fait
cette vidéo la tromperie de la théorie
de l'évolution de Charles Darwin Ulfric
debunk qui a fait 29000 vues et qui
continue de grandir à l'heure où je vous
parle le le nombre de vues s'acroit de
jour en jour plus de 1000
likes et cette vidéo on me l'a envoyé
plein plein plein de fois oh ça vous
voulez que je vous la débun cette vidéo
vous voulez que je vous la débun c'est
je vais vous parler d'un temps que les
moins de 2 ans ne peuvent pas connaître
où j'avais décidé d'arrêter desbunkages
et pénitences parce que ça tournait en
rond parce que les arguments étaient
tout le temps les mêmes on m'envoyait
enfin on m'envoyait je ne me faisais
subir parce qu'au final c'est moi qui ci
je veux dire faut pas non plus je veux
pas mettre le blâ sur les gens qui
partagent généreusement leur envie de me
faire souffrir mais euh c'est moi qui
décide à la fin de me faire souffrir ou
non mais du coup j'avais demandé j'avais
fait un appel une bouteille à la mer
comme ça de d'arguments de de de de
contenu qui produisaient des arguments
qui seraient un peu difficiles à
débunker et surtout des choses nouvelles
parce que ouais je je tournais en rond
quoi après après 14 débunkage et
pénitence je tournais en rond et et et
on m'envoie le cercle
l'ulfric pourquoi vous m'avez envoyé une
vidéo en me disant ça tu vas voir c'est
super intelligent et je scroll et non là
ça a l'air de parler du flagel bactérien
ça a l'air de parler de l'homme de
pildown ça a l' ça a l'air de d'être
encore les mêmes arguments créationniste
bidon que j'ai déjà passé en revue un
milliard de fois c'est pourquoi vous
m'envoyez ça tu as peur qu'on me dit tu
as peur des vrais arguments des bons
arguments non j'ai pas peur des
arguments je les ai déjà écoute bon et
ben ok je vais pas le faire et je dis
non je vais pas le faire je vais pas le
faire et puis bah maintenant cette vidéo
a quasiment 30000000 vues j'ai
absolument pas envie de la faire mais
bon va falloir la faire parce que j'ai
pas envie de la faire et ouais vous avez
gagné vous avez gagné voyez le
harcèlement voyez le harcèlement que je
subis vous voyez là voyez comment je
souffre et alors bah on va on va se
faire subir ça c'est parti
allez en 1859 Charles Darwin oui donc
comme il y a les blockur je précise mais
du coup je le joue sur VLC vu qu'il y a
les blockurs de blocker
ouais donc je l'ai téléchargé je la joue
sur VLC il y a de question que je donne
de l'argent pour ça ni à YouTube ni à
personne
d'autreorig desè considér comme leexte
fondateur de théor de l'évolutionette
dernire vous pouvez entendre que j'ai
mis en accélérer parce qu'il faut pas
déconner non plus la vidéo fait
1h1 sentez que ça va être long
science pourquoi cette idée est fausse
générique ah les gens qui annoncent
générique quand c'est le moment du
générique je vais faire des vidéos où
j'annonce générique mais où il y aura
pas de générique tu sais je vais laisser
juste un silence comme ça générique et
pouf rien pendant une minute et puis
ensuite je
reprends la vie est de fait la chose la
plus fascinante de notre existence cet
acte de conscience se retrouve partout
dans la nature il est dans le soleil et
dans les étoiles dans le jour et dans la
nuit dans les AR dans les fl c'est très
poétique mais la vie dans le soleil hein
les fleurs et Meur avec les feuilles
ilire avec le vent et nous parle dans le
silence de la nuit il est l'aurore et le
crépuscule il est la brume et l'orage la
nature s'incarne s'épanouit sur la terre
la terre se perpétue dans le sang selon
la théorie de Darwin l'incroyable
diversité du vivant émane d'un ancêtre
commun grâce à une sélection progressive
rythmée par l'adaptation au milieu et le
hasard de mutation génétique dans ce là
ça va comment la première cellule
vivante est apparue très bonne question
mais qui n'est pas du ressort de la
biologie évolutive la cellule c'est déjà
une unité c'est déjà une unité qui est
très très loin en fait de l'origine de
la vie elle-même la vie c'est de la
réplication c'est la réplication de
moléculle donc à partir du moment où
vous avez une molécule qui est capable
de se reproduire bah vous avez déjà de
la sélection naturelle qui va s'opérer
puisque les les molécules qui sont
capables de se reproduire plus vite de
faire des copies de elle-même plus vite
vont déjà être naturellement sélectionné
celles qui vont plus vite ou ou qui se
reproduisent ai ou qui se copient plus
efficacement avec moins d'erreur vont
être naturellement plus sélectionné vont
vont se reproduire plus vite plus
efficacement et donc il va y avoir déjà
différentiel de reproduction avec
certaines populations qui vont se
reproduire plus vite que d'autrre et
donc il va déjà y avoir sélection
naturelle donc déjà au stade moléculaire
en fait la la la question déjà est très
très mal formulée la question n'est pas
celle de la première cellule vivante
mais celle de la première molécule
vivante et c'est un sujet qui est
éminemment fascinant et encore très
débattu et à ce sujet du coup bah je
vous recommande la lecture du livre the
evolutionary origins of life and death
de Pierre Duran qui est un livre sur
l'origine de la vie contrairement à ce
qu'il dit enfin ça dit le l'origine
évolutive de de la vie et de la mort
mais l'origine évolutive de la mort
c'est de la mort cellulaire c'est-à-dire
de l'apoptose étant elle-même liée à
l'origine de la complexité l'apoptose
étant un suicide cellulaire et un
suicide cellulaire n'ayant de sens que
dans un organisme multicellulaire donc
comprendre l'origine de l'apoptose c'est
aussi comprendre l'origine de la vie
entre guillemets complexe
multicellulaire euh complexité étant
étant ici comprise par le nombre de
cellules le nombre de tissus vivants
mais surtout les interactions entre ces
cellules c'est-à-dire que certaines
cellules peuvent dire à d'autres
cellules
suicide-toi donc ça l'origine le le ce
livre de Pierre Duran c'est la synthèse
la plus récente sur l'origine de la vie
pas en français hélas j'ai même pas la
prétenension de l'avoir lu en entier
pour l'instant c'est très compliqué à
lire et du coup en fait bah ce que je
m'attends à voir là à partir on est à 1
minute 49 et je m'attends déjà avoir
quelqu'un qui va profiter du fait que ce
genre de livre est très compliqué à lire
euh pour vous raconter des salades que
vous pourrez jamais aller vérifier par
vous-même parce que pour lire ça les
gars faut un master de biochimie au
moins ce que je n'ai pas c'est les
biochimistes qui répondent à la à la
question de la première molécule vivante
la première molécule autoréplicatrice ce
sont les biochimistes qui sont capables
de répondre à ça pas les biologistes
enfin en tout cas pas les biologistes
évolutifs parce que c'est pas notre
domaine de compétenence donc comment la
première cellule vivante est apparue bah
bah Charles Darwin et tous les gens qui
se réclament de la de l'étude de la
théorie de l'évolution après Charles
Darwin s'en foutent voilà donc tu es
horors sujet hors sujet le chapitre qui
va suivre est hors sujet merci au
revoir selon l'tar unien au temps où il
y avait la première cellule qui donna
naissance à l'ensemble de la diversité
terrestre il n'existait aucune
information génétique pour la peau les
cheveux le cœur le cerveau les yeux
ainsi selon eux il fallut générer de
l'information par le seul prisme de la
matière selon ce scénario il y a quatre
et cette phrase ne veut absolument rien
dire générer de l'information près le
prisme de la
matière camouox milliards d'années
divers composés chimique sans vie ont
subit une réaction de l'atmosphère
primimordiale de la Terre dans laquelle
les effets des coups de foudres et de la
pression atmosphérique ont conduit à la
forme de la première cellule vivante
voilà là ce qu'il vient de dire c'est
faux hein ce qu' vient de raconter c'est
le scénario de la soupe primitive et
c'est la création des premières
molécules qui vont servir à la biologie
du vivant plus tard ce qu'il vient de
dire c'est complètement faux en fait
c'est pas ça que les biologistes de
l'évolution ou que les biochimistes
disent ce que les biochimistes disent
c'est que dans la soupe primitive c'est
l'expérience de Miller qui est très
connu c'est on met des des composés
qu'on pense être les composés chimiques
qu'il y avait dans l'atmosphère et dans
la dans l' océan primitif on balance de
l'énergie à l'intérieur sous forme d'une
énergie que à notre avis existait à
l'époque donc ça peut être du soleil
enfin ça peut être de de la lumière ça
peut être des fumeurs noirs ça peut être
de l'électricité c'est généralement de
l'électricité qu'on envoie sous forme
d'orage et enfin qui devait exister à
l'époque sous forme d'orage euh on
balance ça là-dedans et on voit ce qui
se forme et il se forme effectivement
des composé chimique et avec
l'expérience de Miller sachant qu'on l'a
répété plein de fois cette expérience de
Miller on arrive à former tout un tas de
composés biochimiques les composés
biochimiques étant les briques de base
de la de la vie à savoir bah des les
briques de base on arrive surtout à
fabriquer des acides aminés avec
l'expérience de Miller le fait est que
ce n'est que la moitié de l'histoire
puisque on sait aujourd'hui qu'on peut
trouver aussi des acides nucléiques dans
les comètes ou dans des objets
intersidéraux comme ça qui viennent de
l'espace donc on arrive aussi à trouver
les briques de l'ADN et de l'ARN dans
des des objets
spatiaux il y a donc tous les composants
qui servent à l'origine de la
vie tous les composants qui servent à
l'origine de la vie existent déjà ou
peuvent potentiellement exister déjà à
l'état
naturel comme ça juste comme ça par
simple réaction chimique la question
étant comment se sont-ils assemblés et à
ça encore une fois les biochimistes
comme Pierre Duran ont des hypothèses
mais effectivement on ne sait pas
exactement comment ils se sont assemblés
donc il y a par exemple cette cette
argile qu'on appelle la monomorillonite
he de momorillon de monmorillon en
France dans l'Ardèche je crois donc la
la monomorillonite c'est un argile et
apparemment cette argile est capable de
d'agir comme une espèce de si vous
voulez c'est un plateau Lego sur lequel
les briques viennent s'emboîter et donc
elles peuvent former les premières
chaînes d'acid aminé on a découvert
récemment que ça pouvait aussi se faire
enfin les premières chaînes d'acides
aminé même les premières chaînne d'acide
nucléique en réalité on a découvert
récemment que le le magma pouit aussi
servir de catalyseur à l'assemblage de
de chaînes de macromolécules donc de
chaînes moléculaires d'acid aminé ou de
d'ADN de très longue taille on a des
hypothèses alors on n'est pas capable de
dire c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
hein on est d'accord mais on a quand
même des hypothèses on est mieux que on
nen sait rien contrairement à ce que je
suis certain il va nous dire dans 5
minutes que que les biologistes ils en
ont aucune idée donc c'est forcément
magique je sais pas d'ailleurs qu'est-ce
que ça va être son de il a pas annoncé
ce qu'il va essayer essayer de défendre
comme théorie alors est-ce qu'il va
juste nous assembler des arguments
anti-évolutionnistes jusqu'à dire bah
vous voyez on nen sait rien donc c'est
moi qui ai raison sachant qu'il aura
même pas avancé sa propre hypothèse
comme le font la plupart des
antiévolutionnistes hein les les
créationnistes généralement ils ne font
que poser les questions voyez ils
avancent pas vous voyez c'est Dieu qui a
tout fait la plupart des créationistes
se contentent de poser les questions et
de laisser le doute s'isser mais en
réalité ils n'osent pas avancer leur
propres théorie parce qu'ils savent que
leur propre théorie les
bullshit donc est-ce que lui va oser
avancer sa propre théorie bullshit ou
bien est-ce qu'il va en rester à juste
poser des questions on verra bien mais
tout ça c'est du domaine de la
rhétorique poser les questions c'est la
rhétorique la plus simple
encore bref donc déjà là on est sur on
est sur une erreur fondamentale qui est
confondre la première molécule vivante
la première cellule la première molécule
capable d'autoréplication et confondre
la première cellule vivante
qui est déjà un petit sac de
phospholipide avec une une chimie
complexe une biochimie complexe à
l'intérieur qui est déjà un truc qui qui
n'a qui n'a pas pu se former de base
dans la soupe primitive c'est quelque
chose qui s'est formé plus tard on est
déjà vachement plus proche de Luca en
l'occurrence avec la première cellule
vivante la première chose qu'il faut
dire est que l'affirmation Sonel
laquelle des matériaux inanimés peuvent
s'assembler pour former la vie n'est pas
scientifique car elle ne tient
compte les matériaux inanimés écoutez
bien ce qu'il vient de se dire les
matériaux inanimés ne peuvent pas
s'assembler pour former le vivant on va
la remettre on va reprendre exactement
la formulation je veux que vous je veux
votre attention sur cette formulation
pour former la vie n'est pas
scientifique loi physique cell vivante
la première chose qu'il faut dire est
que l'affirmation sel laquelle des
matériaux inanimés peuvent s'assembler
pour former la vie n'est pas
scientifique c'est pas scientifique de
dire que les matériaux inanimés peuvent
former de vivants tu es fait en
quoi vas-y je t'écoute tu es fait en
quoi en atome ouais et les atomes sont
vivants ah non les atomes sont inanimés
effectivement tu as raison tu as
raison tu es fait en quoi bah oui les
les mat tu es fait la vie est faite de
matériaux inanimés qui forme la vie
voilà voilà l'existence de l'être humain
notre cerveau n'est fait que de que
d'éléments biochimique à base de carbone
essentiellement et de beaucoup d'eau et
c'est l'interaction de ces éléments
chimiques inertes les uns avec les
autres des interactions qui sont une
fois de plus purement chimiques he des
on parle de de potentiel d'action qui
créent des courants électriques qui
créent des des passages d'ion à travers
des membranes et c'est ces potentiels
d'action qui créent l'activité de votre
cerveau et qui fait que vous êtes
capable de fonctionner et de balancer
des théories un peu caca comme ça donc
cette affirmation est complètement
fausse vous êtes fait de matériaux
inanimés du même maté et ceci étant dit
du du même matériau inanimé que tout le
reste de
l'univers tout se passe comme si la vie
n'avait rien de spécial en fait nous
sommes fait exactement de de la même
rendons hommage à ubert Reeves voilà
nous sommes faits exactement de la même
poussière d'étoile que tout le reste de
l'univers tout se passe comme si nous
étions nés de l'univers dans le même
univers avec les mêmes enfin comme si on
était à une conséquence
malencontreuse de la de la chimie quoi
finalement
bon donc uber reives voilà c'est pour
toi
uber reives ce doigt du milieu tendu à
la science il était pour toi aussi
visibleement car ne tient compte
d'aucune loi physique ou biologique et
n'a Puut être vérifié par aucune
expérience ou observation la vie na
généré qu'à partir de la vie chaque
cellule vivante est formée par la
réplication d'une autre cellule personne
au monde n'a jamais réussi à former une
cellule vivante en réunissant des
matériaux inanimés pas même dans les
laboratoires les plus
avancés ce n'est pas pas vrai c'est faux
il y a le laboratoire venter de le
laboratoire de Craig Venter le C Craig
Venter Institute pardon qui a réussi à
assembler des cellules synthétiques des
procariotes synthétiques et maintenant
ils ont même clamé avoir fait des
levures synthétiques donc des eucariotes
et tout ça tout ça à partir bah de d'un
ADN enfin ils ont réussi à construire un
ADN qui était complètement artificiel
voilà alors pour ça ils ont utilisé de
la machinerie cellulaire hein parce que
on n' pas encore les machines pour
pouvoir assembler l'ADN donc il faut
utiliser une machine une machinerie
cellulaire préexistante pour pouvoir
assembler l'ADN mais créer un ADN
complètement artificiel ça on est
capable de le
faire c'est juste un problème de
machinerie quoi finalement c'est pas
tellement un problème fondamental de on
ne sait pas insuffler la vie vous voyez
c'est pas c'est pas un problème de magie
hein où il faudrait injecter le souffle
vital à l'intérieur d'une bactérie non
non c'est c'est juste juste un problème
de machinerie c'est un problème purement
technique bon faut dire qu'on n pas
inventé mieux he que la machinerie
cellulaire pour assembler de l'ADN hein
on est bien d'accord mais oui fabriquer
un ADN artificiel on sait
faire dans les années 1930 le
scientifique Oparin formula un certain
nombre de théories afin de montrer
comment la première cellule vivante
aurait pu apparaître à partir de matière
inerte par chance malgré ses efforts ses
recherches se soldire sur un échec et au
Parin lui-même dû admettre que
malheureusement l'origine de la cellule
reste l'aspect le plus trouble de la
théorie de l'évolution citon des gens
des années 30 vous
savez béber qui vivait au Moyen-Âge à
trou du cusoufleuf il a il a il a pas
trouvé comment la vie était apparue
voilà bon bah c'est que c'est qu'il y a
pas de solution à ce grand mystère
osera-t-il seulement mentionner
l'expérience de Miller osera-t-il
mentionner l'expérience de Miller en
effet le plus grand obstacle à
l'encontre de la théorie d'évolution
c'est l'ffroyable complexité de la
structure d'une cellule vivante chaque
chose vivante sur terre est faite de
cellules dont la taille est d'environ 1
centiè de millimèt selon les estimations
le nombre de cellules d'un cor humain
adulte se situ entre 10000 et 100000
milliards les molécules organiques sont
si complexes que leur formation ne
peuvent pas être expliqué comme étant
une coïncidence et qu'il est
manifestement impossible qu'une cellule
organique soit formée par hasard comme
nous allons le démontrer à savoir qu'à
l'époque Darwin la structure il est
impossible qu'une cellule organique se
soit formée par hasard mais c'est pas ça
que la théorie de l'évolution dit ça
devient agaçant à force ça devient très
très agaçant euh la première cellule
vivante n'est pas la première chose
vivante qui soit apparue la première
cellule vivante est apparue certainement
plusieurs millions d'années après la
première molécule capable
d'autoréplication et à partir du moment
où vous avez par hasard effectivement
une molécule capable d'autoréplication
alors ça je suis d'accord c'est un
événement hasardeux mais ceci étant dit
avoir la propriété biochimique de
saautoréplique c'est pas de la c'est pas
de la sorcellerie non plus hein on est
bien d'accord que l'autoréplication
c'est un phénomène qui existe ailleurs
et à partir du moment où vous avez
autoréplication vous avez sélection
naturelle et à partir du moment où vous
avez sélection naturelle il n'y a plus
de hasard il y a encore le hasard des
mutations dans le dans la vie mais si
vous avez sélection naturelle
l'affirmation c'est le hasard est
strictement fausse
ça c'est un truc qu'il faut assimiler
c'est c'est pas parce que le hasard joue
un rôle que c'est le hasard qui fait
tout le hasard ne fait que jouer un rôle
mais à partir du moment où il y a
sélection naturelle
l'affirmation c'est le hasard est
strictement fausse
point donc la première cellule vivante
étant apparue par définition après le la
première molécule
autoréplicatrice tout ce qu' a eu entre
les les deux il y a eu sélection
naturelle des meilleures souches de
molécules
autoréplicatrices donc c'est pas du
hasard finito arrêtez de dire que c'est
le hasard c'est c'est terrible ça
arrêtez de résumer théorie de
l'évolution à hasard c'est c'est
ridicule jamais aucun évolutionniste et
surtout pas Darwin n'a dit ça c'est
fou c'est fou donc oui oui les cellules
me dire tu me dis la la affirmation la
première cellule n'a pas pu apparaître
par hasard est vraie cette affirmation
est vraie elle est pas apparue par
hasard elle est apparue avec un gros
coup de pouce de la sélection
naturelleun cellule était inconnu
néanmoins l'invention au milieu du 20e
siècle de microscope puissant et plus
perfectionné ont commença à dévoiler la
réelle complexité de l'organisation
d'une cellule vivante la théorie
tunienne avance l'idée que les premières
molécules vivantes se sont formées de
manière aléatoire sur ça c'est vrai
voilà là il a employé le mot molécule ça
c'est vrai la première molécule vivante
il a fallu la première molécule
autoréplicatrice il a fallu que ce soit
un assemblage un peu un peu curieux un
peu au pif mais en même temps on est
dans une grande soupe chimique ça fait à
l'époque où la terre est apparue donc il
y a 4 et demi milliards d'années ça fait
déjà 10 milliards d'années que l'univers
est en bouillonnement constant en
bouillonnement physico-chimique
constant étant donné l'étendue de
l'univers et étant donné
la quantité de matière qui interagit
là-dedans avoir des cellules avoir des
molécules autoréplicatrice la
probabilité qu'éventuellement des
molécules autoréplicatrices se forment
là cette probabilité elle finit par
atteindre 100 % parce que juste
l'univers est tellement vaste et il y a
tellement de molécules et de d'atomes
qui interagissent à l'intérieur que oui
bah ça va finir par arriver à un moment
ou un autre donc oui je suis tout à fait
à je suis tout à fait prêt
scientifiquement à accepter que la
première molécule autoréplicatrice donc
vivante et est apparu par hasard mais
encore une fois c'est pas de la
sorcellerie il y a pas de souffle
magique de doigts divins qui sont qui
soi venus
aider millions d'années en se dotant
progressivement de l'ensemble de leurs
caractéristiques par différentes étapes
évoluties cependant les flingèes des
bactéries comme les ciles de certaines
cellules sont constitués par un moteur
moléculaire rotatif très ingénieux et
qui assure leur mobilité dans le cas des
procaryiotes leur fonctionnement
nécessite l'interaction d'une
quarantaine de protéines complexes et
l'absence d'une seule de ces protéines
empêche le flagel de fonctionner ça ceon
appelle le principe de complexité
[Musique]
irductible le principe de complexité
irréductible mes bons amis le fameux
argument on vient me voir on vient me
voir on vient taper à ma porte comme ça
là et puis on me dit mais tu as vu le
flagel bactérien c'est quand même
l'argument béton de contre l'évolution
le flagel bactérien il a pas pu
apparaître tout seul comme un grand he
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
parce que c'est trop compliqué je
comprends pas comment ça a pu se
produire donc ça c'est pas produit
l'argument de la complexité irréductible
en une phrase hein mesdames et messieurs
se résume par je comprends pas pour
comment ça çaa pu faire alors ça s pas
fait je comprends pas comment ma télé
fonctionne c'est Dieu qui l'a fait je
comprends pas comment mon ordinateur
fonctionne c'est forcément Dieu qui l'a
fait donc le flagel bactérien euh et la
complexité irréductible de manière
générale bah c'est justement la le c'est
basé sur l'idée préconçue et fausse une
fois de plus que la sélection naturelle
et l'évolution de manière générale mais
la sélection naturelle en
particulier ne sont pas capable de
générer de structures
complexes ce qui est éminemment faux ce
que les biologistes n'ont jamais dit
jamais alors Charles Darwin il l'a
peut-être dit il y a 150 ans hein mais
Charles Darwin c'était il y a 150 ans
faut faut arrêter de donner autant de
crédit que ça à Charles Darwin Charles
Darwin c'est c'est de la vieille
littérature maintenant on a on a
progressé depuis Charles Darwin il
connaissait même pas l'existence de
l'ADN il connaissait même pas
l'existence des des flagels bactériens
je suis sûr à l'époque donc bref c'était
c'est Charles Darwin c'était il y a très
longtempsut donc Charles Darwin a dit je
suis pas capable d'expliquer le flagel
bactérien même s'il l'a dit je suis sûr
qu'il l'a pas dit mais même s'il l'avait
dit ça vaudrait que dal aujourd'hui donc
la complexité IR réduti ça se contre
enfin c'est déjà c'est basé sur l'idée
préconçue que la sélection naturelle
n'est pas capable de générer des
structures complexes ce qui est
complètement
fou une structure complexe comme le
flagel bactérien en théorie peut-être
apparu à partir d'une structure plus
simple tant que la structure plus simple
est déjà fonctionnelle et ensuite la
structure se complex se complexifie
autour de la de la structure simple et
ça ça va laisser des cicatrices
évolutives ça va Laesser des cicatrices
évolutives c'est si vous avez un flagel
qui fonctionne mais qui est simple et
que il y a des choses qui se rajoutent
par-dessus pour le rendre plus efficace
et que ces choses finissent par se
rajouter jusqu'au point où il finit par
y avoir des structures qui qui ne
servent plus à rien parce qu'elles
servaient au flagel simple mais
maintenant ces structures ont été
remplacées par les structures d'un
flagel plus complexe ces structures
simples par sélection naturelle
normalement devraient être éliminé hein
c'est le principe de la sélection
naturelle ça va retirer du coup des
trucs qui se qui sont devenus redondants
alors redondant ça veut pas dire ça veut
pas dire qu'il y a pas de prospérité
hein ça ce n'est pas un objet avec avec
des prospérité redondant ça veut dire
que c'est des structures bah qui ont un
rôle qui est redondant c'est un rôle qui
a maintenant été remplacé par d'autres
molécules d'autres protéines qui sont
maintenant plus efficaces à jouer le
même rôle c'est ça la
redondance moléculaire donc ces petitte
structures simples elles vont être
retirées à la faveur des structures plus
complexes qui se sont construites autour
et donc vous aurit à la fin un flagel
qui a l'air d'être hyper complexe et on
va se dire wou comment que c'est trop
complexe on peut pas comprendre comment
que ça s'est fait bah non c'est c'est
juste que la simplicité a été enlevée
une fois que la complexité a été
construite autour c'est comme c'est
comme construire un échafaudage un
échafaudage autour d'un immeuble vous
allez vous allez regarder l'immeuble en
vous disant mais cet immeuble là il a
pas pu se construire tout seul bah non
cet immeuble là il s'est pas construit
tout seul il y a eu un échafaudage
autour mais on a retiré l'échafaudage
une fois que l'IM était fini quoi
c'est bon bref et donc l'idée l'idée
derrière ça et là c'est là que c'est
important c'est que si évolution il y a
eu alors on doit trouver des cicatrices
pour ça que je parlais de cicatrices
tout à l'heure mais je suis allé un peu
vite en besogne si évolution il y a eu
il doit rester des cicatrice DEES de ces
structures plus simples et redondantes
il doit rester des trucs qui servent à
rien et c'est ça la grande et et ça ça
va donner un aspect de complexité que
que ce qui est ce que j'avais appelé la
dernière fois qu'on m'a sorti l'argument
du flagel ce qui était il y a pas si
longtemps que ça c'est ce que c'est ce
que j'appelle et c'est ce que aronra
avait appelé la complexité inélégante
c'était un terme que j'avais emprunté à
au youtubeurs aronra abonnez-vous c'est
super bien c'est en anglais par contre
et en plus il a il a un accent texence
qui le rend pas forcément facile à
comprendre pour nous autres mais
c'est la complexité inélégante
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir une
complexité gigantesque certes oui mais
avec des structures à l'intérieur qui
servent à rien c'està-d des structures
qu'un ingénieur regarderait en gros il
regarderait le retort bactérien là ça
fonctionne comme un retort d'hélicoptère
il serait capable de regarder et de dire
mais pourquoi vous avez foutu ça là ça
sert à rien ça et donc ce serait des
structures qu'un ingénieur pourrait tout
à fait un ingénieur ou un grand horlogé
hein comme les comme l'appelle les
créationnistes
euh de aurait dû normalement retirer
donc la certes la complexité
irréductible le problème c'est la
question de la complexité en réalité
c'est pas la question de
l'irréductibilité la question de
l'irréductibilité on on s'en accommode
très bien c'est pas rien n'est
irréductible à partir du moment où on on
imagine justement un échafaudage et la
la sélection naturelle est tout à fait
capable de construire des des structures
complexes comme l'ont démontré les
algorithmes évolutionnaires les
algorithmes évolutionnaires trouent des
solutions complexes que des algorithmes
normaux n'auraient pas réussi à
construire en utilisant quoi bah en
utilisant finalement une une évolution
en mimant une évolution biologique etess
erreur et on copie ce qui marche ESS
erreur et on copie ce qui marche etess
erreur et on copie ce qui marche jusqu'à
trouver la solution à un problème donné
c'est ça un algorithme évolutionnaire
c'est comme ça que fonctionne
l'évolution etess erreur et ce qui
marche est recopié euh donc et avec ça
on arrive à produire des solutions
complexes ce que des algorithmes
n'arrivent pas à produire que des
algorithmes qui fonctionneraient à la
façon grand horlogé justement
n'arriveraient pas à
produire donc c'est aucun biologiste de
l'évolution n'a jamais dit que que la
sélection naturelle était incapable de
produire de la complexité d'une et de
deux aucun biologiste
évolutif n'acceptera l'idée qu'une forme
de complexité puisse être irréductible
puisque la puisque il il suffit
d'imaginer des scénarios où il y a ce ce
que j'ai appelé tout à l'heure des
échafaudages et la cicatrice de ces
échafaudages doit normalement être
visible sous forme de complexité
inélégante c'est-à-dire sous forme de de
de molécules de protéines qui
resteraient dans ces flagelles par
exemple et qui serait redondante
justement n'y aurait-il pas des preuves
de la redondance de certaines de ce de
ces de ces protéines dans les flageles
et bien voici un article qui a été
publié en 2011 hein donc aucune excuse
de pas savoir qu'il existe n'est-ce pas
qui a été publié dans le Journal of
bactteriology journal donc peer review
scientifique tout ce qu'il a de plus
tout ce qui a de plus classique et qui
parle donc de la redondance d'une
molécule qu'on trouve dans certains
flagel bactériens qui s'appelle la
flagéline et dans l'essence ce que N ce
que cet article nous
dit premier paragraphe de la discussion
le niveau observé de redondance est si
grand
que les les filaments fonctionnels donc
de flagéine c'est les filaments
fonctionnels de flagéine formés par les
protéines alors le nom des protéines
c'est flige que fligele fligemux
flligeneux et fligeau pourrait
fonctionner chacun indépendamment donc
vous avez 1 2 3 4 5 types de filaments C
types de protéines capable de produire
des filaments de flagéline et en fait un
seul suffirait alors vous allez me dire
c'est toujours bien d'avoir des petites
copies c'est pour ça qu'il en a tris il
a T de qui merde bon trois
parachutes pas c pas 5 et la la la
flagéine flige J est incapable de former
un filament bactéri voyez la la
flagéline fige j c'est la seule qui
n'est pas redondante c'est la seule qui
n'est pas capable de former un filament
bactérien à elle toute
seule dans un monde où la théorie de
l'évolution enfin dans un monde où
l'évolution ne fonctionne pas tous les
fil toutes les protéines devraient se se
comporter comme la la la FL FL
celle-là tous les filaments devraient se
comporter comme ça et chacun devrait hop
enfin toutes les protéines devraient
former un cran et pouf et elle
s'assemble tout ensemble pour former une
protéine tout entière là là on aurait
des protéines qui sont pas redondantes
et qui formeraient en s'assemblant une
structure complexe au lieu de ça vous
avez cinq copies cinq fois la
possibilité de former des filaments
complètement indépendants complètement
fonctionnels et du coup quatre qui
servent à rien puisque un seul suffirait
largement c'est la redondance c'est la
redondance c'est mesdames et messieurs
la cicatrice dont je vous parlais c'est
c'est une complexité inélégante alors
même quand bien même vous viendriez
m'argumenter mais non mais c'est pas
pour ça que ces copies existent c'est
pour une autre raison c'est il y a il y
a une fonctionnalité différente il y a
machin et tout
on est quand même sur de la redondance
on est quand même sur de la complexité
inélégante on est quand même sur un
design qui est complètement pété un
design qu'un ingénieur viendrait voir et
dirait mais qu'est-ce que vous avez
foutu pourquoi il y a sac moteur il y en
a qu'un qui
fonctionne c'est c'est basiquement ça
hein c'est enfin là on est plus proche
du pourquoi vous m'avez foutu 18 PES sur
votre sur votre truc d'hélicoptère on en
a besoin que de quatre alors vous pouvez
toujours m'expliquer bah au cas où il y
en a une ou deux qui merd mais
fallait juste rajouter de PES de plus
quoi pas mais tu es pas 18 PES quoi les
gars c'est un design inélégant c'est un
produit de la sélection naturelle c'est
un c'est ce qu'on s'attend à voir si la
théorie de l'évolution est vraie à
l'inverse si la théorie de l'évolution
est fausse et que il y a un dessin
intelligent ou que tout a été créé comme
ça magique il y a pas de raison qui est
de merde de merdouille comme ça de de de
redondance au niveau des au niveau de
des protéines
donc ça ça mesdames et messieurs c'est
la preuve que le flagel bactérien il est
pas sorti de nulle part le flagel
bactérien c'est pas un truc qui qui est
apparu comme par magie c'est un truc qui
est issu de la sélection naturelle et de
l'évolution parce que c'est un design
qui a des défauts et que la sélection
naturelle à beau ne
pas la sélection naturelle à beau
pouvoir créer de la complexité elle n'a
pas la prétension de pouvoir enlever
tous les défauts ça c'est pas vrai
alors que dans un dessin intelligent ou
dans un dans une création divine de base
vous aurez normalement pas de défaut
puisque c'est censé être intelligent
comme le dit
le B enfin après après on peut toujours
dire que le grand créateur avait des
défauts hein mais si vous commencez à
dire que le grand créateur a des défauts
c'est pas avec moi qu'il faut en
discuter c'est avec le grand créateur en
question donc en réalité flagel
bactérien disqualifié de milliers de
parties ajustées et interagissantes qui
contribuent chacune à sa fonction
élémentaire l'absence d'une quelconque
de ces parties empêche le fonctionnement
de l'entièreté du
système sauf si c'est Flug de J Flug de
K flux jeeveux l et flux jeeveux m ou
flux jeeveux n flu on voilà sauf si
c'est une de ces CIN là ça ça là ça ira
ça va de sur 3 la vie nous pose un
problème de Poul d'œf sachant que le
code génétique permet de synthétiser les
protéines mais que les protéines sont
indispensables à la réplication du code
génétique lequel des deux est venu en
premier d'ailleurs on remarque que les B
ont une technicité surpassant de moteur
les plus modernes le problème de la
poulée de l'œuf c'est aussi encore une
fois on en avait parlé dans notre vidéo
sur le l'Intelligent Design notre vidéo
sur l'Intelligent Design allez la voir
cette vidéo sur l'Intelligent Design où
on disait alors certes il y a un
problème de poulet d'œuf mais qui de
l'ADN ou des protéines est apparu en
premier sachant qu'il faut l'un pour
faire l'autre et l'autre pour faire l'un
oui mais au milieu faut pas oublier
qu'il y a la
RN c'est pour pas pour passer de l'ADN
aux protéines et de protéines il y a
l'ARN entre les deux et l'érn entre les
deux benah je vous rappelle qu'il y a la
théorie du monde aérn parce que l'airn
il a certaines propriétés
autoréplicatrices et il y a peut-être
une raison pour laquelle cette ARN
existe entre les deux pourquoi encore
une fois dans un dessin
intelligent on passerait de l'ADN aux
protéin du protéine à l'ADN et on aurait
pas besoin d'ARN entre les deux c'est
c'est une étape surnuméraire qui sert
pas forcément à quelque chose pourquoi
cette étape surnuméraire existe encore
bah peut-être parce que à la base on
avait un monde àen bon sachant que la
théorie du monde à RN est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça là je je sursimplifie
parce que j'en ai déjà ma claque mais ça
fait déjà 1 heure que j'y suis j'ai fait
que 5 minutes de vidéo j'en ai ma claque
j'ai pas envie de tout ressortir allez
voir la vidéo mais
voilà encore une fois c'est pas optimisé
même l'histoire de la poule et de l'œuf
en réalité il y a pas qu'une poule et un
œuf il y a il y a un truc entre le la
poule et l'œuf et encore faut faut
l'occulter complètement pour que le pour
que l'argument le contreargument
antiévolutif antiévolutionniste
fonctionne en effit muni de milliers de
parties individuelles appelé protéines
elles sont équipées d'un rotor d'un
stator de coussins d'amortissement d'un
arbre de transmission mais surtout elles
s'autoconstruisent sutorépar sont
capables de tourner à 100000 tours
minute et àer le mouvement bronen cette
pote de tech par contre elles sont
incapables d'aller dans la bonne
direction
c'est ce qu'il vient de dire c'est elles
sont capables de contrer le mouvement
bronien c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont
capable plus ou moins d'aller dans une
direction mais alors je vous je vous
assure que suivre les mouvements d'une
bactérie qui se déplace avec des
rotations de
sonflagel c'est pas du tout comme suivre
une fusée qui va sur la lune hein je
vous annonce immédiatement que ça va
être une autre trajectoire donc oui pas
bronien c'est un gros mot he ce qui
vient d'utiliser c'est de la
vulgarisation de de compète mais en gros
il est capable de contrer un mouvement
bronien ça veut dire que c'est pas
complètement aléatoire mais enfin c'est
pas complètement aléatoire la direction
elle est quand même pétée hein si si
vous avez une direction comme ça sur
votre bagnole autant dire qu'il faut la
changer immédiatement hein donc bon la
direction et surtout c'est et surtout
dans un environnement calme c'est
capable d'aller plus ou moins où ça veut
mais alors dans un environnement c'est
c'est du plan enfin dans un
environnement agité c'est du plancton he
ça va où les vagues vont hein soyons
tout à fait honnête logique à une
efficience% là nos meilleurs moteurs sur
bon ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même de la très très haute technologie
de pointe pour un résultat qui est pas
top qui est maximum pas top bon moi ça
ressemble à de la sélection naturelle
pour moi il y a aucun problème la
sélection naturelle a fait ce qu'elle
peut avec ce qu'elle a encore une fois
je sais pas de quoi il se prétend je
sais pas de quoi il se revendique mais
quelle que soit la chose dont il se
revendique va falloir que ça tienne
compte du fait que le résultat à la fin
est pas top il nous le dira certainement
à la fin de la vidéo ou peut-être pas
moi j'ai fait que poser des questions
atteigne à peine 41 % en plus de ça une
cellule comporte l'équivalent de
centrale électrique d'usine de haute
technologie d'une base de données de
système de stockage des raffineries de
pointe et d'une membrane cellulaire qui
possède une conscience afin de contrôler
ce qui rentre et sort de la cellule d'
membrane cellulaire qui possède une
conscience non c'est des filtres ce qui
ce qui ce qui filtre ce qui rentre et
qui sort de la cellule c'est des filtres
ce sont ce sont des Pors he
des c'est juste des filtres c'est tout
il faut faut qu'il y ait une affinité
moléculaire à l'entrée et si cette
affinité c'est les c'est le principe des
anticorps enfin c'est le principe des
des antigènes pardon c'est si si si ça
si ça s'emboîte c'est bon ça passe si ça
s'emboîte pas ça
dégage c'est pas une conscience du tout
c'est juste une affinité chimique de
base c'est tout je puisse survivre tous
ces organites doivent être
interconnectés et fonctionner
simultanément il est donc impossible
qu'un système si complexe puiss avoir
émerger par le pied de
coincidence alors il faut que ces
organites fonctionnent tous en même
temps alors c'est ce qu'il a appelé les
centrales nucléaires là c'est les c'est
les myoconderes ce qu'il a appelé les
base de données c'est l'ADN enfin le le
noyau encore que ça s'applique pas aux
bactéries ce qu'il a app je sais plus ce
qu'il a appelé mais il y a d'autres
organites à l'intérieur faut que tout ça
fonctionne en même temps et donc c'est
trop compliqué et donc la vie elle a pas
pu apparaître comme ça bah encore une
fois on parle d'une cellule déjà
fonctionnelle à ce point-là donc ça
n'est pas apparu par hasard c'est apparu
par sélection naturelle de deux bah ça
existerait pas si ça fonctionnait pas en
fait c'est c'est une totologie en fait
ce qui vient de dire c'est une immonde
totologie c'est évidemment que ça
n'existerait pas si tout ça ne
fonctionnait pas ensemble mais c'est le
principe typ de la sélection naturelle
c'est si ça fonctionne pas ça disparaît
donc évidemment que ce que tu vois
devant les yeux fonctionne puis puisque
c'est ce qui a survécu les les tout ce
qui marche pas par définition est mort
c'est la sélection naturelle
ce il en est de même pour la paroie
cellulaire la membrane cellulaire les
mitocondries les protéines l'ADN laarn
les ribosomes les lysosomes Caire no et
d'Es par C
plusuneé la simplericationécule deé de
taille moyenne est déjà composé de
28 différ qui peuventtre combinés de00
manères différentes SAF que de toutes C
diverses probabilités une seule forme la
molécule de protéine nécessaire à la vie
et il existe plus de 600 com pluses jou
et tout ça fonctionne par simple
affinité chimique de molécules inanimé
c'est que de l'affinité chimique
l'assemblage l'assemblage des protéines
c'est que de l'affinité chimique on est
capable de tout expliquer par simple
affinité chimique c'est juste des trucs
qui s'emboîent si vous préférez si vous
aimez pas le terme affinité chimique
c'est juste des trucs qui s'emboîent et
on est tout à fait capable d'expliquer
comment ça se passe sans faire appel à
la magie donc ce qu'il est en train de
vous dire c'est du bourrage de de
trognon avec des gros mots qui font très
peur et des grosses statistiques qui
n'existent pas mais en réalité c'est
aucun souci aucun souci à expliquer tout
ça c'est de la pure chimie c'est de la
pure biochimie de molécules qui sont par
ailleurs complètement
inanimé je rappelle du coup le
fonctionnement d'un flag n'a pas pu se
réaliser par la gradualité nos systèmes
biologiques sont bien trop complexes et
harmonieux pour être le résultat de
l'évolution par des mutations au hasard
ou par la sélection naturelle harmonieux
mais [__] regardez le fonctionnement
d'un flagel bactérien regardez la façon
dont se déplace une bactérie et
dites-moi que c'est harmonieux quoi
professeur de biologie moléculaire alors
qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit l'université
américaine de cbec a calculé la
probabilité qu'une seule protéine
c'est-à-dire une séquence d'acide aminé
émerge par hasard en un milliard
d'années et on a déterminé qu'elle
serait d'une chance sur 10 puiss 74 mais
il existe encore d'autr obstacles ou
encore une fois si vous assemblez une
protéine comme ça la une de ces
protéines là qui est qui est déjà une
protéine qui a 4 milliards d'années de
sélection naturelle dans sa face
oui la probabilité que ça ça semble par
hasard elle est proche du néant je suis
d'accord mais personne dira le contraire
mais encore une fois sélection naturelle
la sélection naturelle n'est pas le
hasard bisous êre surmé car la chimie
nous apprend que si nous voulons
construire une protéines les acides
aminés doivent être reliés ensemble avec
ce qu'on appelle des liaisons
peptidiques dans la nature une liaison
peptidique se produit environ une fois
sur deux donc pour former une protéine
son environ 150 acid Amin de longueur
une fois sur de de
quoi une liaison peptidique se forme une
fois sur de une une fois sur de de quoi
donne-moi 5 % s'il te
plaît quoi
donne-moi 5
% une fois une fois sur deux de de quel
intervalle de temps de 149 vous avez une
chance sur de de chaque côté d'obtenir
le bon type de liaison donc une chance
sur 2 mulp par une chance sur 2 sur une
chance sur 2 et ceeta exposant 149 on va
rir à 150 il s'avre qu'une chance sur 2
explosant 150 est ég à 10 pu 45 donc au
total la probabilité pour obtenir qu'une
seule de ces protéines fonctionnelles
par chance est de 10iss
164 heureusement que les bactéries ont
une machinerie cellulaire qui permet
d'aider à l'assemblage de ces protéines
il essaie de nous démontrer qu'un flagel
bactéria sassemblera pas dans un verre
d'eau chaude mais encore une fois aucun
darwinien n'a jamais dit ça enfin aucun
biologiste évolutionniste au monde n'a
jamais dit ça hein à titre de
comparaison 10^iss 16 serait le nombre
de secondes entre le déclenchement du
Big Bang jusqu'à nous si tentz qu'il a
eu lieu car encore le Big Bang ce n'est
qu'une théorie mais ça donne tout
simplement un ordre d'idée sur
l'improbabilité du hasard l'astronome
Fred o a comparé les chances que toutes
les parties à multiples facettes et
multifonctionnelles d'une une cellule
puisse se réunir par coïcidence et crée
de la vie à une tornade balayant une
casse et assemblant un Boeing 747 à
partir des matériaux qui s trouvent
Jeffrey Bada un professeur de géochimie
des plus grand c'est très marrant de la
part de l'astronome Fred o de dire que
le Big Bang n'aurait pas pu assembler un
Boeing 747 par parce que c'est ce que le
Big Bang a fait en fait
ubert reves la poussière d'étoile que
nous sommes a assemblé un Big Bang 747
cette même poussière d'étoile qui a été
créée quand quand durant le bing bang
donc si en fait le le Big Bang est
capable d'assembler un Boeing 747 si on
lui donne 14 milliards
d'années en partisant de la théorie de
l'évolution av voie ce fait dans le
magazine es de février 1998 aujourd'hui
alors qu'on arrive au 21e siècle nous
n'avons pas résolu le problème soulevé
au début du 20e siècle à savoir comment
la vie a-t-elle commencé sur terre
phrase éminemment sortie de son contexte
ceci dit c'est une vidéo qui est sortie
quand c'est c'est c'est une vidéo qui
est sortie l'année dernière en 2022 en
2020 22 citit un article de
vulgarisation scientifique même pas un
article scientifique mais citit un
article de vulgarisation scientifique de
1998 on a fait quelques progrès depuis
hein confire livre de Pierre Duran on a
fait quelques donc on est toujours pas
capable de répondre non mais on a de
sérieuses idées he encore une fois
sortie de contexte tout ça tout ça
toi-même tu sais les phrases sorties de
contexte ça aideent on a toujours pas
réussi non on a toujours pas réussi à
mettre le doigt sur the truc mais enfin
ça veut pas dire qu'on a aucun une idée
de ce qui se passe c'est toujours pareil
docteur Warner kit est un des
spécialistes de l'information génétique
dans son livre au début de l'information
il dit un système de code est toujours
le résultat d'un processus mental cela
requier une forceinttelligence la
matière est incapable de générer du code
par elle-même il n'existe aucune loi
naturelle connue aucun processus et
aucune séquence d'événement qui peuvent
causer de l'information à émerger tout
seule à partir de la matière autrement
dit c'estàdire
je je je vous traduis au cas où pour
ceux qui seraient impressionnés par
cette citation c'est je vous traduis
c'est si on ignore complètement
l'ADN
alors aucun système d'information n'est
capable d'être générer par autre chose
qu'une
intelligence ah bah oui oui oui si si
vous prenez l'ADN qui est la forme de
codage qui est apparu naturellement par
par la enfin par les lois qui régissent
la théorie de l'évolution pas seulement
la sélection naturel il y en a beaucoup
d'autres mais bref si vous excluez
totalement l'ADN de votre notre
raisonnement et si on l'ignore
complètement et si on le laisse comme ça
et puis non l'ADN ça existe pas bla BL
alors oui on ne peut pas générer du code
autrement que de manière consciente de
manière intelligente certes certes mais
est-ce que tu as pas l'impression d'être
parti de la conclusion pour arriver au
raisonnement plutôt que
l'inverse donc oui si vous êtes
impressionné par cette phrase ne le
soyez pas c'est une totologie peut rien
créer à partir de rien c'est qui tout
même assez logique richardkins d'
interview un des plus grands partisans
de la T évolution il est capable de dire
on est pe on est on ne peut rien créer à
partir du rien après avoir parlé du Big
Bang moi je dis ça je dis rien Richard
Dawkins qu'est-ce qu'on va encore sortir
de son contexte de Richard Dawkins
est-ce qu'on va essayer de faire passer
Richard Dawkins pour un créationiste là
il y a là il y a si si c'est ça il y a
un niveau de balls mesdames et messieurs
mais alors qui est cosmique vas-y
sors-nous une phrase de son contexte
pour faire dire à Richard Dawkins des
trucs de créationniste a ét incapable de
citer un seul exemple d'un processus qui
augmente l'information génétique dans le
génome avant d'être convaincu
aujourd'hui que la compxité de la vie de
l'univers émane d'une intelligence
supérieure Richard Dawkins n'a pas été
capable de citer un seul phénomène un
seul attends la phrase exacte la phrase
exacte un seul exemple d'un processus
qui augmente l'information génétique
dans un seul exemple de processus qui
augmente l'information génétique vous
avez vu ça en 6e et ça s'appelle la
copie oui quand vous copiez un gène vous
générez de l'information G éque et le le
phénomène de copie de gène est un
phénomène avéré je vais pas revenir sur
le programme de 6e ça c'est hors de
question le programme de 6e SVT on va
pas revenir
dessus bon non c'est peut-être le
programme de secondes à la limite mais
en programme 2 secondes normalement on
n'est pas spécialisé encore ah quoi que
peut-être maintenant vous êtes
spécialisé je sais pas les jeunes
dites-moi les jeunes dites-moi est-ce
que vous êtes spécialisé maintenant
quand vous rentrez au
lycée donc le programme de seconde en
tout cas à l'époque où j'étais en
seconde c'était alors le programme de
Seconde les mutations génétiques les
mutations génétique dans le programme 2
secondes
elles sont les
suivantes attention ça va ça va être
rapide dans le programme de Seconde ah
non de premières PSVT en première PSVT
allez admettons c'est pas en seconde
premiè PSVT on apprend la substitution
l'addition la déltion
l'addition
alors alors la substitution c'est quand
on
remplace une base dans l'ADN l'addition
c'est quand on ajoute une base dans
l'ADN la Délion c'est quand on enlève
une base dans l'ADN l'addition
l'addition ajouter ajouter de l'ADN
ajouter de l'information génétique
toi-même tu sais voilà donc si tu veux
citer Richard Dawkins qui est pas
capable de dire un phénomène qui
augmente la quantité d'information dans
l'ADN je suis presque sûr que c'est un
mensonge donc on les voit en première S
on les voit en première S mais je suis
sûr que Richard Hawkins a le niveau
première S et de toute façon il existe
un phénomène qui s'appelle donc la la
copie de gène tout simplement à savoir
que par exemple c'est le cas des
homéogènes les gènes architectes ceux
qui contrôlent votre morphogénèse la la
formation de votre corps de manière
générale toute votre embryologie ces
gènes c'est il a été complètement établi
que ces gènes sont en fait des copies
les uns des autres et c'est des copies
qui chacune ont muté dans leur coin en
fait et c'est comme ça qu'on génère de
la nouvelle information génétique et
très honnêtement c'est pas de la science
c'est pas ce qu'on appelle de la rocket
science c'est de la science de base
comme je disais he le le concept
d'addition de de base de nucléotide
c'est un concept de lycée et le concept
de copie de
gène non je crois qu'on voit ça aussi au
lycée hein ou alors au pire en première
année de fac mais bon
tout le monde n'a pas le niveau hein
puis évidemment le truc c'est que quand
on quand on est comme Monsieur ulfrick
et qu'on ne fait que copier-coller des
arguments qu'on a vu quelque part
ailleurs dans un site créationniste
américain débile bah forcément qu'on ne
fait que répéter des arguments déjà
débiles ça c'est un argument extrêmement
débile c'est cracher sur Richard Dawkins
c'est un truc de créationnistes
américains parce que ça ça les énerve
c'est des créationnistes anglophones ça
les énerve Richard Dawkins parce qu'il a
toujours raison parce que ça fait depuis
les années 70 qu'à chaque fois qu'il
sortte un nouvel argument il dit ben non
c'est
faux donc évidemment arriver à cracher
sur Richard Dakin si vous voulez c'est
un sport pour les créationnistes
anglophones mais quand on est un petit
peu quand on est un petit peu à cours de
connaissance et qu'on a juste envie de
dire moi je suis contre la théorie de
l'évolution parce que j'aime pas l'idée
d'avoir un un africain dans mon arbre
généalogique et ben évidemment on va
chercher des trucs anti-évolution là où
on les trouve le mieux c'est-à-dire sur
des sites de créationnistes américains
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah on copycle
les conneries qu'ils ont dit donc le
flagel bactérien truc débunké depuis des
millions d'années on prend des citations
hors contexte de Richard Dawkins mais
qui ne veulent absolument rien dire je
veux dire de on aurait dit on aurait
effectivement posé cche la question à
Richard Dawkins donne-moi un phénomène
qui augmente l'information dans l'ADN
évidemment qu'il aurait dit addition et
copy g parce que c'est ça qui se passe
c'est donc on ajoute de l'information
dans l'ADN aucun problème bah copie le
couple copie de gène plus mutation de la
du gène copié qui là effectivement
ajoute de l'information mais cette
mutation après ces mutations après
peuvent se faire par simple substitution
par exemple donc
bref c'est non encore un mauvais
argument merci bisous génome avant
d'être convcu aujourd'hui que la
complexité de la vie de l'univers émane
d'une intelligence supérieure les débuts
de la vie ah ça y est il commence à
accoucher de sa théorie bullshit à lui
d'une intelligence supérieure et man
d'une intelligence supérieure c'est de
là ça y est le créationisme le
créationisme il est là jusqu'à présent
on était que sur de l'antiévolutionnisme
de base je fais que poser des questions
mais là ça y est le créationnisme on le
sent on le voit il est là les débuts de
la vie n'ont pas été aléatoires ils
doivent avoir été le produit d'une
intelligence délibérée dès ma première
formation de scientifique je suis bien
lavage de cerveau très poussé pour
croire que la science ne peut être
compatible Laage de cerau doulourusement
abandonné pour le moment je ne trouve
aucun argument rationnel pour renverser
le point du qui PLA pour la conversion à
Dieu nous avions l'habitude d'avoir un
esprit ouvert maintenant nous réalisons
que la seule réponse logique à la vie
est la création et non un mélange
aléatoire accidentel le docteur Lesli
Orgel associé de Francis cric sachant
que techniquement votre éducation
religieuse commence bien avant votre
éducation à la science avoir l'esprit
ouvert consisterait plutôt à écouter les
scientifique qu'à continuer à écouter
les gens qui vous ont bourré la tête
d'idée que c'est Dieu qui a créé la vie
non l'ouverture d'esprit c'est la plus
mauvaise excuse pour la fermeture
d'esprit que j'ai jamais entendu je je
ne cesserai de le répéter les gens qui
vous demandent d'avoir l'esprit ouvert
sont les gens qui ont l'esprit le plus
fermé en réalité ce sont les gens qui
précisément n'écouteront pas les
arguments que j'ai sortis depuis tout à
l'heure et qui vont commenter là en
disant mais non tu as pas tu as tort
parce que si parce que ça parce que ça
ils vont me sortir des millefeuilles
argumentatifs exactement comme cette
vidéo qui le découvreur de l'ADEN en
personne AR il est extrêmement
improbable que des protéines et des
acides le docteur Lesli Orgel associé de
Francis Crick qui est le découvreur de
l'adenne en
personne c'est on est tellement en panne
d'autorité qu'on va chercher le pote du
mec qui a découvert l'ADN a écrit il est
extrêmement improbable que des protéines
et des acides nucléiques qui sont tous
deux structurellement complexes se
soient formés spontanément au même
endroit au même moment pourtant il
semble également impossible d'avoir l'un
sans l'autre et donc non mais jusque-l
ce qu'il dit c'est pas faux hein c'est
oui non c'est c'est improbable que ces
protéines se soient formées comme ça oui
oui oui oui mais c'est pas ça qu'on dit
première vue on pourrait concl jamais pu
en fait provenir de moyens chimiques
comme l'a déclaré le professeur
évolutionniste Ali de mirirsoy la
probabilité de la formation fortuite du
cytochrome c'est l'une des protéines
essentielles à la vie est aussi
improbable que la possibilité qu'un
singe écrive l'histoire de l'humanité
sur une machine à écrire sans faire
aucune erreur certaines puissances
métaphysique au-delà de notre définition
doiv B jusqu'à jusqu'à aucune erreur
pareil c'est l'affirmation est vraie la
probabilité que que le C que le cychrome
C apparaî de façon fortuite est
effectivement aussi probable que celle
qu'un singe éccrive l'histoire de
l'humanité sans erreur je ne m'arrêterai
pas sur le fait que l'être humain est un
singe qui a écrit l'histoire de
l'humanité mais bon en l'occurrence on
ne l'écrit pas sans erreur mais
euh encore une fois le c'est le même
concept de raisonnement que le bing bang
mais bref aucun évolutionniste n'a dit
que le cytochrome c était apparu de
farce for T le cytochrome c est issu
d'un processus de sélection naturelle
d'évolution par les les les lois de la
théorie de l'évolution qui inclut la
sélection naturelle et qui n'est donc
pas fortuite qui n'est donc pas d au
hasard donc pareil aucun problème aucun
problème le cochrome C ne faisait pas
partie du package des molécules
autorépliquantes qui sont à l'origine de
la vie ce n'est pas un problème ce n'est
absolument pas un problème personne n'a
dit çair dans formation suppons qu'il a
des millions d'anées soité une cellule
alors à quel point tu es désespéré pour
citer
Araya je ne sais pas
Araya grand instigateur grand
instigateur de l'Atlas de la création et
violeur d'enfants à ses heures perdues
à quel point tu es désespéré d'autorité
pour aller citer
aruniaya je vous laisse 2 he pour y
réfléchir quoi qu' quoi qu'il s'apprête
à dire dans la prochaine phrase c'est ça
va être bullshit nécessaire à la vie et
qu'elle est d priv vie la théorie de
l'évolution s'effondre à nouveau à ce
stade car même si cette cellule avait
existé pendant un certain temps elle
serait finalement morte et après sa mort
rien ne serait resté et tout serait
revenu à son point de départ en effet
cette première cellule vivante dépourvue
de toute information génétique n'aurait
pas pu se reproduire et démarrer une
nouvelle génération la vie aurait pris
fin avec sa
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui globalement globalement une une
bicouche phospholipidique qui se promène
sans rien à l'intérieur on va pas on va
pas s'attendre à ce qu'elle se
reproduise
effectivement c'est Toto qui vous
raconte une totologie voilà on devrait
dire c'est Yaya majeur que pose la
question de la théorie d'évolution à
celui des espèces en transition en effet
selon la loi de la sélection naturelle
tout n évolution les espèces
transitoires les fameux schémas où on
aperçoit des poissons se transformés
progressivement en reptiles sortant de
l'eau selon la ouais ouais bah ça on on
est bien d'accord que stade 1 de de
l'idée reçu c'est que ce ce schéma là
est sursimplifié théorie de l'évolution
l' espèces existant se transforme au
cours du temps en une nouvelle espèce
chacun de ces processus de
transformation est censé sêtre accomplli
progressivement pendant des millions
d'années s'il en allait ainsi
d'innombrabl espèces de transition
aurait dû être présente dans chacun de
ces processus de changement d'un côté il
aurait dû avoir dans le passé mais je
vais faire comme si je n'avais jamais vu
aucun livre de paléontologie et je vais
faire comme si ces espèces transitoires
n'existaient pas donc auchiot ticalque
auchiot archéoptérique auchiot
australopitèque auchiot voilà des formes
de transition des créatures mixtes qui
présenteraient par exemple en partie des
caractères de poisson en partie des
caractères de reptiles c'est vrai ça en
partie en partie c'est j'adore parce
qu'en fait à chaque fois tu vois les les
les créationnistes qui te disent ah il y
a aucune espèce de transition entre le
poisson et le reptile ah bon tu connais
pas un animal tu connais vraiment pas un
animal
dont la vie est en grande partie inféodé
à l'eau comme un poisson qui pendant une
partie de sa vie a une queue comme un
poisson et nage comme un poisson et
débranchi comme un poisson et qui dans
une autre partie de sa vie a toujours
une vie relativement inféodé à l'eau au
moins pour sa reproduction mais euh est
capable de se déplacer sur terre et à
quatre pattes comme un tétrapode comme
un reptile donc comme ce que toi tu
appelles un reptile tu es vraiment sûr
que tu connais aucun animal
qui a une biologie de poisson pendant
une une étape de sa vie et une biologie
quasi reptilienne une biologie quasi
poisson dans une étape de sa vie une
biologie quasi reptilienne dans une
autre étape de sa vie après une
éventuelle métamorphose au milieu tu es
vraiment sûr que tu connais pas que tu
as jamais vu dans ta vie de grenouille
tu promets est-ce que tu es vraiment en
train de me
promettre que dans ta vie tu n'as jamais
entendu parler du concept
d'amphibien le battra chien tu ne
connais pas le battra
chien mais non mais ils font exprès de
sauter du poisson au reptile pour te tu
sais t'embrouiller l'esprit mais dit
mais tu connais vraiment pas le concept
d'amphibien ça te ça te passe
complètement au-dessus de la tête le
concept d'amphibien donc et je suis sûr
qu'il va nous dire ça alors qu'il va
nous mettre un amphibien à l'écran en
plusre côté des millions de stades de
développement des organes ah voilà levla
ton amphibien devrait pouvoir être là là
le truc là qui vient de nous montrer là
regarde regarde regarde regarde attends
je te le remets je te le remets là ça là
ce qui est à l'écran là ça a une queue
d'amphibien et ça a quatre pattes c'est
itiostega on l'a dans le registre
fossile cette bestiol là aussi ridicule
que cette animation puisse être là un un
animal qui a un corps globalement de
poisson une queue de poisson et quatre
pattes c'est itiostega c'est tikalic
c'est comment il s'appelle déjà j'ai
oublié elpistost g tout ça on les a on
les a dans le registre fossile ces
bestiau là alors Milon de stade de
développement des organes et des
extrémités devraiit pouvoir être mis en
évidence mais tous les animaux connus
par leur pétrification ainsi que ceux
qui vivent
[Rires]
[Musique]
au il est mignon il est mignon parce que
ça ça c'est semuria et semuria c'est un
reptiliomorphe c'est un amphibien en
transition vers les reptiles c'est Muia
c'est donc un amphibien il a le nez
arrondi des amphibiens il a le crâne qui
a des des qui est un peu bulbeux un
petit peu un petit peu paterné comme ça
très rugueux comme des amphibiens euh
son squelette généralement est celui
d'un amphibien mais par contre il a les
yeux au lieu de les avoir sur le sommet
du crâne comme un amphibien parce que
les amphibiens ils regardent a-dessus de
l'eau il enfin les amphibiens du Permien
j'entends ils avaient les yeux audessus
de la tête et il chassaient il chassai
comme des crocodiles en regardant
au-dessus de l'eau bah c'estoura lui
c'était un animal qui était terrestre
donc ses yeux au lieu d'être sur le
dessus vous voyez très très clairement
ils sont sur le côté et c'est Muria il a
deux vertèbres sacrées donc deux
vertèbres qui s'accroche à la ceinture
pelvienne au lieu de une seule comme les
amphibiens donc deux vertèbres sacrées
c'est un caractère de de reptile c'est
une c'est une accroche très forte à la
ceinture pelvienne une seule vertèbre
sacrée c'est une c'est une accroche à la
ceinture pelvienne qui est très faible
c'est un caractère d'amphibien parce que
ils sont semi-aquatiques ils ont pas
besoin de d'avoir le le bassin très
accroché à colonne
vertébrale donc il vous dit qu'il y a
pas de il est en train de vous balancer
qu'il n'y a pas de forme transitionnelle
dans le registre fossile tout en vous
mettant
c'estouria la forme transitionnelle
entre amphibien et reptile la classe
mondiale peut-être même le champion du
monde c'est
prodigieux c'est prodigieux mais c'est
un très piètre choix d'illustration par
contre paraisse parfaitement développé
et idéalement adapté de tel animaux
transitoires av réement existé on
devrait avoir les fossil ou on devrait
les avoir les fossiles je devrais
pouvoir vous les montrer dans ma vidéo
antiévolution sil
[Rires]
exist créés dans les
AR Darwin dit d'espèces transitoirees
dans le registre fossile en
[Rires]
1880 en 1880 on n pas des même pas
Charles Darwin c'est quand l'origine des
espèces
1860 en 1860 il y a pas d'espèces
transitoire dans le registre fossile
sachant qu'en 1862 je crois on a
découvert l'archéoptérix donc en réalité
dans les édition suivante de L'Origine
des espèces il y a effectivement un
passage où il dit bah non finalement les
formes transitoires on les a trouvé on a
découvert archéoptterrix qui est mi
reptile
mioiseau on va citer l'édition numéro 1
de L'Origine des espèces Charles Darwin
qui balance bah il y a pas de forme
transissoire bah oui en 1860
on est en
2023 c'est quasiment pareil à l'échelle
d'étang géologique c'est c'est la même
chose oh la vache prendre de l'état des
connaissances de 1860 pour démontrer
qu'on a raison à quel point est-ce que
c'est pathétique
à quel point est-ce qu'on en est au
niveau de
l'argumentation pour ne tellement avoir
rien à dire qu'on va citer un mec qui a
vécu qui a écrit son truc en
1860 je suis pas de années près me
sortez pas la date exacte de la sortie
de L'Origine des espèces on est pas
années près 1859 non je sais plus bref
je m'en fiche on s'en fiche de L'Origine
des espèces c'est un truc c'est pareil
c'est les les créationnistes américains
étant fondamentalement ultra religieux
on cette idée en fait que Charles Darwin
était un messie pour les
évolutionnistes donc pour eux remettre
en question Charles Darwin enfin il ne
conceptualise même pas la possibilité
que les évolutionnistes puissent
remettre en question Charles Darwin et
je vous assure qu'en tant
qu'évolutionniste j'en ai rien à [__]
de dire que Charles Darwin il a dit de
la merde
mais même si Charles Darwin avait dit il
y a pas de preuve dans le registre
fossile donc ma théorie est fausse ben
je m'en aurais rien à [__] parce qu'on
les a découvert depuis les preuve j'en
aurais rien à [__] je dirais bah
Charles Darwin il a dit de la merde un
point c'est tout Charles Darwin encore
une fois il avait pas les fossils il
avait pas l'ADN il a eu une intuition
géniale il a eu il s'est donné les
moyens de vérifier cette intuition et de
vérifier que son intuition était
correcte mais il avait il a pas pu tout
savoir Darwin n'est pas le Messie de la
théorie de l'évolution et encore une
fois ça se voit là ça dégueule par tous
les ports que ce qu'il a fait c'est
juste copiercollé des argument de
créationniste américain pourquoi bah
parce que il s'imagine enfin là Charles
Darwin est cité comme étant le Messie de
la théorie de l'évolution ce qui est un
trait typique du créationniste du
créationisme américain de s'imaginer que
les évolutionnistes sont comme eux sont
coincés sur un bouquin voilà comme ils
arrivent pas à comprendre comme eux ne
réfléchissent que sur la Bible il arrive
pas à comprendre que nous on arrive à
réfléchir sur autre chose que l'origine
des espèces l'origine des espèces c'est
un bouquin qui est
obsolète ne lisez pas l'origine des
espèces à part si vous avez un intérêt
pour l'histoire des sciences mais si
vous voulez apprendre la théorie de
l'évolution l'étape 1 c'est pas
l'origine des espèces prenez un bouquin
récent sur la théorie de l'évolution
prenez le guide critique de l'évolution
de le Cointre ça c'est un bouquin récent
et encore maintenant il il doit avoir 10
ans maintenant ce bouquin en réalité
même lui il commence à se dater mais au
moins vous aurez des trucs à peu près à
jour l pas Charles
Darwin donc Charles Darwin je même pas
écouter
espéit que des formes transitionnelles
d'espèces animales évion progressivement
en différentes espèces encore une fois
il il est capable de nous dire les
formes transitionnelles n'existent pas
il vous les montrre
osténoptéron
pandéctis tiktaalic
itiostegaantostega bonne question
pederpes je me rappelle plus exactement
mais bref ils existent tous he
finalement découvert un moment futur
dans les archives fossiles sauf qu'à ce
jour aucune forme de transition de ce
type n'a jamais été retrouvé
mais il est capable il est capable de
vous dire comme ça straight face il est
capable de vous dire poker face il y a
aucune forme de transition en vous les
mettant à l'écran le gars il est
balaise estuse Brit il
est ce so de l'ordre de l'espèce un
pointessort quoi que ce soit que nous
trouvons ce n'est pas une évolution
progressive mais l'explosion souaine
d'un groupe ah ça c'est ça c'est les
équilibres ponctués c'est l ou
G ah non c'est Hager ah bon je le
connais pas la dire on nous a ressorti
on nous a ressorti des équilibres
ponctués de son contexte des équilibres
ponctués qui éta donc une réponse
justement au créationnisme en
disant ingénieur voilà quelle autorité a
ce monsieur ingénieur pour parler
d'évolution il n a aucune merci
B ah c'est le premier créationniste que
j'entends enfin utiliser le registre
fossile des chauve-souris comme preuve
antiévolution depuis le temps que
j'arrête pas de le dire parce que là il
nous met les baleines là mais voilà
enfin enfin quelqu'un qui a compris à
qu'il fallait arrêter de reprendre les
arguments des créationnistes américains
des années 70 appuyer là où ça fait mal
appuyer sur le registre fossile des
chauv-souris oui ah bah voilà enfin il y
a du challenge enfin il y a du challenge
bon c'est dommage ça
sort je fais ça littéralement une
semaine après avoir sorti ma vidéo sur
l'évolution des chauve-souris mais et
qui donc répond à toutes les questions
sur l'évolution des chauve-souris mais
donc c'est dommage c'est mauvais timing
très mauvais timing enfin mauvais timing
pour eux pour moi c'est tout se passe
comme si euh la grâce m'avait
touché il y a un dessin intelligent
regardez-le il est beau il est
intelligent il
fonctionne ah oiseaux c'est pareil euh
donc l'explication des évolutionnistes
serait que non pas les oiseaux non les
Oise les oiseaux on a tout ce qu'il faut
forme de transition mer
bisit vol mais cont tu plus vite
commoup il P plus
suréate ce scénario de merde qui
nous plus ou ouais c'est surtout plus à
jour maintenant on a établi que les les
dinosaures enfin les dinosaures à la
transition dinosaur oiseau étai plutôt
arboricol et du coup ils sont il planeur
de la même façon que les écureilles
volants sont planeurs
quoive et en plus on a Yi qui a une
membrane de peau exactement comme un
es sont complètement formé son comme
aujourd'hui mais pourtant encore une
fois alors elles sont pas comme
aujourd'hui exactement les premières
justement là qui tu as appuyé sur
l'endroit où ça fait mal je vous invite
à aller voir ma vidéo sur l'évolution
des kiropter mais pour vous la résumer
non les premières chauve-souris ne sont
pas complètement formé et déjà des
chauvees-souris oniconic teris
contrairement au chauve-souris modernes
a encore des griffes sur le bout des
doigts elle a encore une longue queue et
elle surtout la forme de ses ailes
montre qu'elle était à la fois planeuse
et volante ce qui est un mode de
déplacement qui n'existe quasiment plus
chez les chauve-souris modernes mais
elle était du coup à la fois planeuse et
volante donc tout se passe comme si
onicon nictteris cétait elle-même
descendante d'un animal qui était
planeur donc effectivement la
chauve-souris planeuse on l'a pas la
chauve-souris strictement planeuse qui
serait le parfait intermédiaire entre le
petit insectivore arboricole et le la
chauve-souris on l'a pas ça je suis
d'accord on l'a pas encore ça viendra un
jour mais en je suis convaincu que ça
viendra un jour et peut-être plus
récemment que vous ne
l'imaginez mais on a quand même une idée
de comment ça s produit et on a des
preuves de comment ça s produit et
surtout ben on est capable de regarder
les boutons génétiques des chauve-souris
et de dire bah
c'est c'est ce bouton génétique là qu'il
faut appuyer et pou vous faites
apparaître une membrane ça on a aucun
problème à le montrer le répéter comme
l'exemple du coup de la Gira c'est quand
même qui est communément admis de dire
là tu citais l'exemple des ailes que
voilà on aurait eu au début des espèces
qui avent des petites ailes ça leur
aurait permis de de survivre et puis et
pourtant c'est pas ça pas l' aussi
simple que ça quoi moi obtivement je
pense pas que ça soit passé comme ça
parce que vu que les oiseaux c'est
objectivement je pense pas que ce soit
passé comme ça nous dit Monsieur
l'ingénieur qui n'a jamais fait de
biologie évolutive percer et çaut
pasouvé est-ce qu'il y a ça aussi ça pas
de fossile d'oiseau l'AR l'archéoptérix
il y a une explication un petit peu de
certains de c'est les milliers de
fossiles chinois qu'on a il y en a un
qui sort tous les 15 jours mais à part
ça on a jamais
retrouvé certain millions mais en fait
par exemple pour les dinosaures on plus
100000 les oiseaux 200000 les ches
souris j'ai plus chiff en tê plusieurs
dizaines de milliers et C et en fait
c'est super comp une analogie qui est
très bonne c'est imagine tu commences à
chercher des coquillages sur la plage et
en fait bah tu dis je vais voir un peu
tous les C au début plein c'est t début
ils sont différents et pu for de cherou
T les mêmes et à un moment B faut
vraiment que tu passes beaucoup de temps
pour rechercher un Nant les Foss c'est
un peu pareil le registre fossile est
quand même très très complet et donc en
fait
l'analogie mais qui ne marche absolument
pas du tout non les coquillages que tu
retrouves sur la plage sont les seuls
qui ont pas été défoncés par les vagues
donc en fait tu as un biais
d'échantillonnage dans tes coquillages
que tu ramasses sur la plage tu ne
ramasseras jamais la totalité de la
biodiversité des coquillages qui existe
dans le monde juste en te baladant sur
la plage même en te baladant sur tous
les toutes les plages du monde il y a
des coquillages qui vivent au fond de la
mer que tu ne verras jamais il y a des
coquillages qui sont trop fragiles et
qui du coup vont être complètement
défoncé par les vagues
euh et il y a des coquillages qui nont
même pas de coquille du tout en réalité
il y a des molusques qui n'ont
absolument pas de coquill hein comme les
Céphalopodes par exemple donc tu tu tu
ne les verras jamais bah le registre
fossile c'est pareil il est pas complet
pour exactement les mêmes raisons voilà
et et s'imaginez que le registre fossile
est complet c'est mignon mais comment
dire ton si ton argumentation commence
dans l'idée en partant du principe que
le registre fossile est complet
ouais tu es mal barré tu es tu es
gravement mal barré muscle ton mè si tu
muscles pas ton jeu fais attention je
t'assure tu vas voir tu vas voir des
déconvenus maintenant pour trouver des
nouvelles espèces fa vraiment énormément
chercher la plupart de ce qu'on trouve
non nous on en retrouve tous les ans
dans le
carou et des vertébrés en plus he pas
des pas des
coquillages en fa par il y a des
milliers littéralement des milliers de
nouvelles espèces qui sont décrites
cha
la micro versus la macro
évolution mais qui c'est qui m'a sorti
que c'était des arguments nouveaux là
[__] donc allez on va nous dire que
oui alors les espèces elles évoluent oui
mais pas trop pas suffisamment pour
former des alors oui mais ça évolue mais
pas trop mais pas suffisamment pour
former une nouvelle espèce et puis vous
avez jamais vu un papillon se
transformer en cheval alors l'évolution
elle est pas vraie et puis [__] des
gens qui vont encore nous argumenter que
les les dunes ne sont pas fait d'un
empilement de grain de sable parce que
c'est ça là l'argument de la
microévolution de la macroévolution
c'est que les l'évolution qu'on observe
à l'échelle microévolutive c'est-à-dire
à l'intérieur d'une espèce si on la
prolonge dans le temps bah le l'idée des
des évolutionnistes c'est que si vous
avez deux populations qui commencent à
diverger bah en se prolongeant dans le
temps ça va donner deux espèces et ce
que les créationnistes ils disent c'est
bah non si vous avez deux populations
qui commencent à diverger à l'échelle
microévolu et ben ça va jamais former
deux espèces pourquoi ta gueule c'est
magique voilà donc si vous prolongez un
phénomène qui a déjà lieu et que vous le
prolongez suffisamment longtemps dans le
temps comme l'accumulation de grains de
sable bah vous finirez pas par former
une dune non non non accumuler les
grains de sable ça forme pas les dunes
non non non
c'est alors je vais vous je vais vous
parler d'un exemple sur les
chauvees-souris tiens puisqu'on en parle
des chauve-souris vous avez chez les
chau-souris les chau-souris quand elles
utilisent des ultrasons elles utilisent
des harmoniques je vous invite à voir la
vidéo d'y penser sur les harmoniques si
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est mais en
gros c'est une note c'est pas qu'une
seule note en fait c'est la même note à
plusieurs octaves donc dans une note
quand vous entendez une note vous
n'entendez pas qu'une seule note vous
entendez la enfin c'est même pas à
plusieurs octaves c'est à plusieurs
intervalles en réalité donc c'est une
harmonique donc ce que vous entendez
c'est pas une note c'est un accord en
réalité et ça ça vient du fait que bah
si vous avez une corde en fait elle va
vibrer
et faire un son mais les extrémités de
la corde en réalité elles vont pas
vibrer en faisant elles vont vibrer plus
vite en fa parce que les extrémités des
cordes bah voilà elles sont plus près de
vos doigts là par exemple elles sont
plus près de vos doigts donc elles vont
pas vibrer à la même fréquence et donc
ça va faire un son une note différente
et plus vous vous approchez proche de la
de votre doigt et plus la vibration va
être rapide donc plus la note va être
différente de la note du milieu là donc
la note du milieu c'est la dominante et
puis vous allez avoir d'autres notes au
fur et à mesure que vous vous rapprochez
donc voilà ça c'est une harmonique donc
les chauve-souris utilisent leur cordes
vocal et donc produisent des harmoniques
par définition puisque le son faut bien
qu'il sorte de quelque part donc elles
produisent des harmoniques et elles
utilisent plusieurs harmonique
d'ultrason et en fait ce qu'on a observé
c'est que chez certaines populations de
chauve-souris je crois d'Afrique du Sud
euh vous avez différentes populations de
la même espèce enfin qu'on considère
comme étant de la même Mme espèce et qui
utilise les mêmes harmoniques mais
chacun utilise une dominante différente
donc vous avez celles qui utilisent la
grosse dominante du milieu
la et puis vous avez celles qui vont
utiliser les les petites vibrations plus
rapides comme dominantes donc ils vont
utiliser des notes plus aigues ou plus
enfin chaque chaque population va
graves en fonction de la dominante
qu'elles ont choisie ça permet en en
l'occurrence de chasser différentes
ressources puisque en F en fonction de
la note que vous utilisez pour faire
votre écolocation pour produire vos
ultrasons vous n'allez pas chasser le
même type de proie les proies plus
grosses vont être chassées avec des
notes plus graves et les proies plus
petites vont être chassées avec des
notes plus aigues parce que les notes
plus aigu ont une plus haute fréquence
et du coup c'est plus facile de de
choper des petits objets que des gros
objets et les gros objets à l'inverse
sont plus faciles à capter avec des
basse fréquence en des fréquences
relativement basses hein ça ça reste des
ultrasons donc ces populations elles
arrivent finalement c'est même pas des
populations qui sont forcément séparées
en réalité c'est des populations qui
vivent qui peuvent vivre plus ou moins
l'une sur l'autre parce que de toute
façon ell n'exploit pas la même
ressource justement parce qu'elles
utilisent différentes dominantes d'une
même gamme
harmonique donc c'est la même espèce
elles utilisent toute la même harmonique
mais pas la même dominante sauf que sauf
que les les les les les bruits que que
les chauves-souris produisent ces sont
ils joue un rôle dans la reproduction
aussi et donc on s'attend à ce que ces
populations qui utilisent des dominantes
différentes vont aussi utiliser ces
mêmes notes pour communiquer les unes
avec les autres et ça ça va résulter en
des isolat de reproduction à savoir que
bah si vous êtes un utilisateur de telle
ou telle dominante bah vous allez vous
reproduire avec d'autres qui vont
utiliser telle ou telle dominante les
femelles vont vont préférer telle ou
telle dominante parce que les sons sont
font partie du du rituel qui conduit à
la reproduction donc en fait à
l'intérieur de ces de cette grande
espèce de chauve-souris ce qui va se
passer c'est que chaque population va
s'isoler de plus en plus au fur et à
mesure qu'ils vont se spécialiser vers
cette dominante pour se nourrir mais
aussi pour se
reproduire et et donc la conséquence
attendue si l'évolution est vrai la
conséquence attendue de ça c'est que
quelque part dans le monde il doit
exister plusieurs espèces de
chauve-souris
où on voit les restes de cet événement
de de spéciation
théorique donc pour l'instant on parle
d'un événement de spéciation théorique
c'està-dire que si vous avez les espèces
qui enfin les populations à l'intérieur
d'une espèce qui s'isole de plus en plus
l'isolat reproductif va être tel qu'au
bout d'un moment elles ne vont plus
pouvoir se reproduire du tout entre
elles et ces populations vont produire
des espèces différentes chacune étant
spécialisée vers une harmonique
particulière et si c'est vrai si
l'évolution est vraie alors on doit
pouvoir trouver aujourd'hui des espèces
qui ont subi ça qui ont subi ce
phénomène donc trois espèces différentes
par exemple qui utilise chacune euh une
dominante des de de cette
harmonique enfin de de cette gamme
harmonique mais qui ne sont plus
capables de se reproduire entre elles et
ben ça existe ça existe on a des espèces
de chauve-souris je vous les mettrai à
l'écran maintenant parce que j'ai plus
les noms là mais je vous mettrai ça à
l'écran on a des espèces de
chauve-souris où tout se passe comme si
elles utilisaient chacune des dominante
d'une même gamme harmonique issue d'un
ancêtre en
commun donc tout se passe comme si bah
il y avait eu isolat reproductif et que
chaque espèce avait fini par s'isoler
complètement génétiquement de ces deux
autres cousines par
exemple donc ça si la théorie de
l'évolution est vraie on a une très très
bonne explication de pourquoi plusieurs
espèces différentes de chauve-souris
utiliserait les dominantes issues d'une
même gamme harmonique donc chacune
s'étant spécialisée dans une dominante
particulière au point de devenir
complètement génétiquement isolé et donc
de former une nouvelle
espèce comment tuexpliques ça quand tu
es
créationniste c'est c'est ce que là où
je veux en venir c'est cette différence
entre micro et macro évolution donc la
formation des espèces qui chacune s'est
spécialisée à une harmonique et juste le
prolongement logique de ces isolements
de population qui avaient lieu déjà à la
base et qu'on observe aujourd'hui chez
les chau-souris modernes on observe ça
chez les chauv-souris modernes des
groupes qui s'isolent en fonction enfin
qui s'isolent au moins du point de vue
écologique et reproductif on les a ces
souspopulations qui s'isolent parce que
comme j'ai dit elles peuvent se
recouvrir du point de vue géographique
c'est pas un souci puisque de toute
façon elle ne communique pas Z elle ne
communique pas de la même
façon mais donc ces isolements on les
observe chez les chauv-souris modernes
donc ça c'est la microévolution ces
petits isolements c'est pas encore des
espèces différentes elles sont encore
capables de se croisé et on observe des
espèces qui sont bien séparées mais qui
utilisent chacune une harmonique comme
si elles avaient évolué de la façon
qu'on dont on avait fait l'hypothèse sur
les les populations donc les populations
c'est la microévolution les trois
espèces séparées c'est la
macroévolution et effectivement je peux
pas vous vous dire c'est exactement
comme ça que ça s'est passé je peux pas
vous faire le pont entre la
microévolution et la macroévolution ça
c'est pas possible enin c'est pas
possible étant donné les connaissances
actuelles je peux pas exactement faire
ce pont entre la micro et la macro
évolution mais par contre c'est la
solution logique c'est la c'est le
prolongement logique et ben pour les
créationnistes c'est de la
science-fiction il y a un mur entre les
deux et c'est un mur
c'estàdire que vous observez un
phénomène et vous faites l'hypothèse que
si ce phénomène d'isolement de chacune
des populations se prolonge dans le
temps et ben il se passera rien sil
continue à pas forniquer les uns avec
les autres s' continue à s'isoler s
continue à rien à voir les uns avec les
autres à pas agir de la même façon à pas
utiliser les mêmes notes pour chasser ou
pour conquérir des femelles ou des mâles
je sais pas dans quel sens ça se passe
d'ailleurs Jez les chauve-souris mais
bref pour communiquer entre mâle et
femelle et ben ils vont quand même
rester de la même espèce parce que ta
gueule c'est
magique c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
l'ADN mais alors pas du tout l'ADN ça ne
marche absolument pas comme ça mais eux
ils croient que
si ils croient que c'est magque donc
c'est aussi stupide que ça de séparer la
microévolution de la
macroévolution et par ailleurs on est
tout à fait capable de créer des
nouvelles espèces en
laboratoire j'en ai déjà parlé plein de
fois on a créé un nouveau lézard un
nouveau lézard en laboratoire qui a trop
de chromosomes donc qui peut se
reproduire avec aucun lézard de son
espèce par contre il est capable par
contre ce lézard avec trop de
chromosomees euh qui donc par définition
ne peut pas se reproduire avec aucun
autre membre de son espèce d'origine
donc est une nouvelle espèce à part
entière il est capable de se enfin elle
est capable de se reproduire par
parténog génèse donc elle est capable de
générer une population c'est une espèce
c'est ce qu'on appelle une espèce une
nouvelle espèce et on s'est pas gêné
pour lui donner un nom donc on est
capable de créer des nouvelles espèces
en
laboratoire on est capable de théoriser
des nouvelles un mécanisme pour générer
des nouvelles
espèces mais pour les créationnistes il
y a un mur magique entre les
deux l'ancienne vivante qui
correspondrait au modèle d'évolution
progressive par gradualité et qui est
pourtant essentielle dans la théorie
d'unienne nous allons aborder plus en
détail la raison pour laquelle un tel
processus est contraire au lo naturel
c'est là qu'il faut distinguer deux
types d'évolution différentes
premièrement il y a la micro évolution
qui est une évolution au niveau de
l'espèce a chang à pe échelle à besoin
d'adaptation dans n environn
ceomè par
ça la CRÉ de nè encore une fois je je
vous laisse je vous laisse admirative
devant quelqu'un qui
citewi un exemple typique Dar avait
étudé les différentes races de pinons
des Galapagos avait conclu que les
animaux par une suite de PE déviation
pouvait se transformer en une autre
espèce alors que ce n'était pas le cas
comment est-il venu à cette alors que ce
n'était pas le cas alors que ce n'était
pas le cas il balance comme ça entre la
poire et le fromage alors que ce n'était
pas le cas donc les passons de Darwin ce
sont des espèces différentes he comme
l'indique le fait qu'ils ont des noms
différents et puis ils ont tous la même
gueule à plus ou moins une taille de bec
près alors soit tu fais l'hypothèse que
il y a une population ancestrale qui
s'est adapté à différentes sources de
nourriture et du coup leur bec s'est
changé voilà la la nourriture qui les
grosses graines ça fait des gros becs et
les les petits trucs les petits insectes
ça fait des petits becs les petits
insectes tendres ça fait des petits
becs ou bien tu fais l'hypothèse que ta
gueule c'est magique la magie bon ben
semblerait-il que Ulfric préfère ta
gueule c'est magique les LO dehérédité
de Mendel selon ces lois c'est ce qu'on
appelle les caractères cachés sautent
d'une ou plusieurs générations pour
ensuite surgir à nouveau rien à voir
avec la microévolution la macroévolution
les carères CWI prenait pour un nouveau
caractère chez les pinons en réalité
uniquement une nouvelle combinaison de
caractères subordonné qui était déjà
présent dans la série de leur ancêtre
l'objection principale contre la théorie
de la sélection naturelle est que cette
dernière ne réussit pas à faire
apparaître un caractère essentiel
survenant pour la première fois
d'ailleurs c'est assez logique une
espèce ne peut évoluer qu'à partir des
gènes qu'elle comporte déjà grâce à ses
ancêtres quand au rôle des mutations
nous y reviendrons plus tard voilà les
pinons sont restés des pinons c'est ce
que je vous disais quand je vous disais
le le papillon il s'est pas transformé
en cheval donc c'est pas de l'évolution
voilà les pinons sont restés des pinçons
ouais mais enfin il y a il y a
différents genres et espèces au sein des
pinons de Darwin c'est alors en plus il
il ne sait même pas ce que c'est que de
la macroévolution en réalité parce que
la macroévolution c'est la spéciation la
la limite
fondamentale de la macroévolution c'est
la spéciation c'estàdire que tant qu'il
y a pas spéciation tant qu'il y a pas
isolement reproductif il y a pas
macroévolution donc tout ce qui se passe
à l'échelle intaspécifique c'est
microévolution tout ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur de ça c'est la
macroévolution donc il ne sait même pas
ce que veut dire macroévolution c'est
quelqu'un qui est en train de de vous
faire une thèse sur la macro évolution
qui ne sait même pas ce que le mot macro
évolution veut dire il n'a même pas ne
s'est même pas fait chier àer vérifier
sur
wikipédiais carè je sais même pas
pourquoi je l'écoute je sais même pas
pourquoi je perd du temps
làus é un rôle important dans la théorie
Darwin car constitue le modèle
permettant de justifier le fait qu'un
reptilien pourrait devenir avec des
millions d'années un homme évidemment
évolutionexiste part que ce soit dans
arch il rest un poisson même avec des
millions et des millions d'années plus
tard s'il sort de l'eau il mourra
aussitôt C voilà c'est de
l'essentialisme un poisson reste un
poisson on est complètement sur
quelqu'un qui l'essentialisme c'est
comme je vous dis c'est la barrière
magique c'est ça l'essentialisme au fait
que le poisson se transforme en
reptilien par la force du temps et de la
sélection lié à un milieu à une théorie
transformiste qui explique l'évolution
des êtres vivants par l'infence directe
du milieu qui se nomme le lamarchisme en
référence à Jean-Baptiste de Lamarque
sauf que le lamarquisme a été
aujourd'hui abandonné car il ne tient
compte d'aucune réalité puisque vous
aurez beau essayer de faire respirer un
alors si tu es de la marquise à ce
momentlà c'est à peu près aussi
pertinent que d'aller faire un footing
pour expliquer l'origine de la vie
ou ou je sais pas moi ou d'aller faire
un McDo pour aller sur la Lune par
exemple voà c'est à peu près aussi
pertinent que ça CIT l'amarchisme ici il
dit qu'il voit pas le rapport de l'eau
il
mour c'est une référence culturelle vous
avez vu je suis jeune et je suis jeune
et
branché po car cela leur donnera une
meilleure adaptation le nombre
d'individus de grande taille augmentera
simplement grâce au fait que les
poissons qui pourront se reproduire et
survivre seront ceux qui génétiquement
sont les plus grands avec le temps la
taille globale de cette espèce pourra
beaucoup augmenter mais il en restera
des poiss c'est quand il va falloir se
reproduire avec la population des petits
poissons ils vont voir des petits
poissons et ils vont juste les bouffer
ils vont pas se ils vont pas essayer de
se reproduire avec c'est tout le
principe microévolutif
prenons un troupau de Gazell est menacé
par des lions naturellement celles qui
survivent sont celles qui peuvent courir
le plus vite mais qu'on s'enentente bien
ce processus ne transformera jamais les
gazelles en une espèce vivante
différente les gazelles resteront
toujours des Gazelles indépendamment de
la durée de ces processus de sélection
même si peut-être les gazelles au jambes
par il est en train de vous dire il est
en train de vous dire vous pouvez pas
prédire le futur alors j'ai raison c'est
ça qui vient de dire
traduisez vous pouvez pas prédire le
futur donc j'ai
raison je vous laisse juge je vous
laisse seul juge de de la validité de
cette
logiqueune faculté de transformer une
espèce en un autre animal et donc le
truc c'est que le nwinisme essae
d'élever la mutation comme cause de
changement avantageux au même niveau que
la naturelle fait
pas non tu as rien compris au
darwinisme il d'élever mutation au même
rang que la sélection naturelle mais non
les deux fonctionnent ensemble
descendance avec modification et
sélection naturelle c'est ça l'évolution
c'est c'est les deux en même temps c'est
pas l'un ou l'autre ou l'un plus
important que l'autre l lis un livre lis
un livre vraiment arrête de lire juste
les les créationnistes américains Liv
prouver par la macroévolution ils
essayent de vous le faire prouver par
les mutations sauf que pour démontrer
l'existence de mutation agissant
positivement pardelà l'espèces les
généticiens darwiinistes ont eu l'idée
d'élever depuis des décennies des
mouches de fruits parce que ces insectes
se reproduisent très vite et que les
mutations apparaissent de ce fait très
rapidement vous le savez certainement on
a découvert que l'irradiation
radioactive élève considérablement le
nombre des mutations l'irradiation fait
apparaître à côté des mouches à yeux
noirs des mouches à yeux rouges de
avaient des ailes plus petites plus
grandes ou multiples il apparaissaient
différents exemplaires en outre on a
exposé des générations de mouches à des
conditions extrêmes de chaleur de
lumière d'obscurité et de substances
chimiques toutes ces mouches furent
croisées en tous sens il apparu
plusieurs variantes mais en dépit
d'innomrables tentatives il s'agissait
toujours génétiquement de la même mouche
qu'au début logique les expériences sur
les drosophil n'ont jamais eu pour but
de démontrer que la théorie de
l'évolution était vraie on les les
expériences enc encore une fois c'est du
programme c'est du programme de de de
lycée quand on vous parle de l'évolution
quand on vous parle des drosophiles
c'est pas de l'évolution des espèces
qu'on vous parle c'est on vous parle des
gènes des homéogènes donc ce qu'on a
fait en faisant muter les mouches
c'était on a cartographié leur génome
grâce aux mutations c'estàdire en
regardant à chaque fois là où ça merdait
ça a permis de dire où est-ce que sur le
chromosome ça merdait donc ça quand on
appuie sur ce bouton là ah ça change ça
bon ben alors le gène de ça ça veut dire
qu'il est localisé là sur le chromosome
et quand on appuie sur ce bouton
génétique là ah ça change ça donc ça
veut dire que ce gène là il est là sur
le chromosome et ça c'est on n jamais
essayé de démontrer la théorie de
l'évolution avec les drosophiles mé
Gordon Tyler AC lu dans tous les milers
d'expériences de croisement des mouches
qui ont été accomlies pendant plus de 50
ans dans beaucoup de parties de la terre
on n'a jamais pu observer l'apparition
d'une nouvelle espèce on n jamais pu à
on n jamais pu observer l'apparition
d'une nouvelle
espèce parce que on n pas essayé
même d'un nouvel enzyme alors une enzyme
c'est une protéine et je suis presque
sûr que si tu trifouilles les homéogènes
des des drosophiles tu feras apparaître
des nouvelles protéines c'est un
mensonge la pratique montre que les
mutants soit meurent soit sont stériles
soit reviennent au type naturel la même
chose faut pour l'évolution humaine que
l'on veut propager toutes les mutations
observées sur les hommes avaient des
conséquences nociives déformation
corporelles ou consomption comme le
mongolisme l'alpinisme le nanisme ou le
cancer c'est faux c'est faux chaque être
humain porte 35 50 et 100 mutation voilà
par exemple un article de 2000 donc
c'est un article qui est assez vieux qui
estimait déjà que il y avait 175
mutations par génération BIM 175
mutations par génération le sa depuis
l'an 2000 et puis là vous pouvez cliquer
voilà il y a des overview proposés par
science direct donc par des éditeurs
scientifiques où on vous donnera
plusieurs chiffres différents mais quoi
qu'il arrive ces chiffres seront
différents de zé donc ce qu'il vient de
vous dire c'est complètement faux que je
sache vous enfin je veux dire si vous
portez vous-même des centaines de
mutations qui diffèrent de entre vous et
vos parents et on parle bien de mutation
pas seulement de recombinaison génétique
bah ça fait de vous des mutants et
pourtant vous êtes vous êtes pas
anormalement déformé et cetera et cetera
hein donc non c'est tout aut strictement
pas l'espèce en tant que t en une autre
espèce dans le livre évolution Ross Mo
confirme le travail dans un grand nombre
de laboratoires a montré que la plupart
des mutations sont nocives et que les
mutations drastiques évolue même
habituellement vers la mort elles
empreintent en quelque sorte la mauvaise
direction en ce sens que toute
transformation dans un organisme
harmonieux bien adapté à des
répercussions négatives la plupart des
porteurs de mutation profonde ne reste
pas assez longtemps en vie pour
transmettre à leurs descendant des
modifications encore une fois programme
de lycée
l'adrpanocytose laadrpanocytose quand
vous êtes hétérozygote vous êtes protégé
contre le
paludisme
laadrpanocytose pourtant c'est une
mutation des léteres hein je veux dire
si vous êtes homozygote drpanocytose
vous êtes mort effectivement mais quand
vous êtes hétérozygote ça vous protège
contre le Palu la sélection naturelle
tue ceux qui sont
homozygotes tue ceux qui sont sensibles
au palu donc qui n'ont pas de ce gène de
laadrpanocytose et conserve seulement
ceux qui sont homozygotes de telle sorte
qu'on voit une différence génétique
claire entre les gens qui sont issus des
populations autochtones et les gens qui
ne le sont pas comme
moi de nouveau tout ça c'est une
question de bon sens c'est comme si on
essaie de mon plan et qu'on joue au D
pour ter du placement de T ou telle
pièce déjà le is ne sera pas amélioré
mais surtout endommagé ou mieux on
nobservera aucune répercussion et il en
va de même pour le cas des mutation
c'est faux la mutation n'apporte aucune
nouvelle information la d'un organisme
les particules porteuses de
l'information si l'addition l'addition
apporte de nouvelles puisque ça apporte
par définition un un
nouveau un nouveau nucléotide à
l'intérieur de l'ADN là ce qu'il nous
montre c'est une c'est
une
ah une substitution j'avais oublié le
mot ce qui nous montre là c'est une
substitution mais oui une substitution
ça appte une une nouvelle ça apporte un
nouveau nucléotide donc on pourrait
discuter hein de de la nouveauté de
cette de cette apport mais une addition
ça rajoute par par définition sont soit
arraché à leur place soit détruites soit
placé en un autre endroit les mutations
ne peuvent pas permettre à un individu
vivant la formation d'un nouvel organe
ou d'une nouvelle propriété elles
peuvent uniquement causer des
anormalités si vous copiez un gène vous
le placez ailleurs un gène se copie se
place ailleurs et se met à muter de son
propre côté ça crée un nouvel ça crée au
moins une nouvelle protéine c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec vos
yeux hein vous êtes vous avez une vision
triichromatique pourquoi parce que vos
ancêtres avaient une vision
dichromatique tous les mammifères ont
une vision dichichromatique en tout cas
tous les mammifères plein cinter ont une
vision dichichromatique mais chez les
primates ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
y a un des gènes qui donné cette vision
dichromatique qui s'est dupliqué qui a
muté et qui a donc donné une vision
triichromatique c'est juste une
duplication de gène qui a créé une
nouvelle un nouvel organe en
l'occurrence des
récepteurs bisous encore une une fois
programme de lycée comme par exemple un
doigt en plus ou une oreille sur le
ventre pour pouvoir être transféré d'une
génération à la suivante une mutation
doit avoir lieu dans les cellules
sexuelles de l'organisme une
modification forttuite survenant dans
n'importe quelle cellule ou n'importe
quel organe du corps ne peut pas être
transmise à la génération suivante Colin
Patterson paléontologue SEOR British
c'est vrai c'est vrai si ça touche pas
les organes génitaux enfin si ça touche
pas les cellules de la lignée germinale
ça ne se transmettra pas mais ça veut
pas dire que ça n'arrive jamais heom of
Natural History et ardent évolutionniste
admet lui-même que la sélection
naturelle n'a jamais été observée comme
provocquant réellement l'évolution de
quoi que ce soit personne n'a jamais
produit une espèce par des mécanismes de
sélection naturel sexclameil ensuite
ilose que
certainstil encore une bonne
grosse encore une bonne grosse
affirmation sortie de de son contexte
n'est-ce pas donc il a dit ça quand
vas-y on propose que certains reptiles a
évolué avec des ailes paléentolog
seigneur du British Museum of Natural
History et ardent évolutionniste admet
lui-même que la sélection naturelle n'a
jamais été observée comme provoquant
réellement l'évolution de quoi que ce
soit personne n'a jamais produit une
espèce par des mécanismes de sélection
naturelle
non mais on a produit des espèces par
même en en partant du principe que
l'affirmation est vraie on l'a fait par
un principe de sélection de sélection
artificielle qui fonctionne exactement
comme la sélection naturelle
c'est-à-dire que seul les individus qui
portent certains traits se reproduisent
par sélection artificielle on a fait
apparaître le cheval domestique on a
fait apparaître le chien domestique on a
fait apparaître le chat domestique on a
fait apparaître tout ce qui est
domestique et qui est considéré comme
des espèces différentes donc de la
macroévolution on a juste accéléré le
processus de sélection naturelle par le
processus de sélection artificielle mais
c'est le même principe en soi donc le la
barrière micro macro évolution on l'a
franchi et on l'a franchi on l'a vu se
franchir puisqu'on a vu ces espèces
apparaître ns autres
humains donc c'est pareil encore un
autre argument comme quoi cette barrière
micro macro évolution elle n'existe que
dans leur tête ensuite il propose que
certains reptiles ai évolué avec des
ailes et soi devenus des oiseaux tandis
que d'autres reptiles ont évolué et sont
devenus des mammifères par exemple les
œufs d'amphibien ne se développent que
dans l'eau alors que les ufs amtiques se
développent uniquement sur terre oui
c'est il dit qu'il voit pas le rapport
entre les oiseaux les reptiles les œufs
les machins en quoi les œufs en quoi
cette histoire d'œuf est un exemple de
ce que tu viens de dire avant c'est même
même le le discours est incohérent au
possible sorte scénar d'volu progressive
par étape impossible puis sansèce peut
pas survivre les prétend évoluant sans
parfait et complet une espèce ne peut
pas survivre c'est quoi un œuf parfait
et complet
hein qu'est-ce que tu appelles un œuf
parfait et complet un œuf avec une
coquille avec une coquille dure les les
ornitorin et les tortues produisent des
œufs à coquimol alors qu'est-ce que
c'est le
problème c'est quoi le problème il y a
des centaines littéralement des
centaines de reptiles qui ont des œufs
tellement pas parfaits et tellement pas
complets qu'ils sont OV vivipar c'est
leurs œufs sont tellement imparfaits
qu'il les gardent à l'intérieur jusqu'à
ce que le machin est close
donc de quoi super pas mammifère en son
un autre exemple les reptiles sont à
sang froid pr des ufs n'allent pas leurs
petits ont trois de la mandibule et des
corps recouvert d'écailles tandis que
les mammifères c'est tellement c'est
tellement essentialiste attends on va
laisser finir sa phrase juste pour que
vous compreniez juste gardz en tête
ornitorin Gez en tête ornitorin pendant
qu'il dit sa phrase des bulles et des
corps recouverts desca devenus des
oiseaux tandis que d'autres reptiles ont
évolué et sont devenus des mamifè par
exemple les œufs d'amphibien ne se
développent que dans l'eau alors que les
œufs se développent uniquement sur terre
donc une sorte de scénario d'évolution
étap par étape est impossible puisque
sans parfait et complet une espèce ne
peut pas survivre c'est là c'est là
voilà pensé ornitorinque les reptiles
prétendument évoluant en mammifère en
sonit un autre exemple les reptiles sont
à sang froid onent des ufs n'allaitent
pas leurs petits ont tris de mandibule
et des corps recouverts d'écaill tandis
que les mammifères sont à sang chaud ont
des naissances sortant directement de
leur mère alla leurs petit ont trois
moyens une mandibule et son recouvert de
four ou de poils beaucoup trop de
différence distinctes pour une évolution
progressive ah si seulement on avait un
animal qui qui était à la fois un
mammifère et pondait des œufs tu sais
genre une espèce intermédiaire tu vois
truc comme ça
ah
ah bloody essentialism ah
l'essentialisme c'est chiant
l'essentialisme parce que ça marche pas
quand il y a encore des des monotrèmes
ah c'est dommage par ailleurs les EAU de
la mandibule il y en a pas trois chez
les reptiles il y en a se et des animaux
qui sont ancêtres des mammifères et qui
ont effectivement SEP zoau dans la
mâchoire on en a ça s'appelle des
Synapsides enfin ça s'appelle des
pélicosaures les pélicosaures puis les
thrapsides donc les pellicosaures qui en
ont se les thraapsides ensuite qui en
ont où on voit le nombre se réduire
jusqu'à ce que les cynodontes ont un
gros os qui domine largement les six les
six autres OS les six autres os dont
trois vont disparaître et trois autres
enfin deux autres en l'occurrence c'est
donc vont devenir les osselet de
l'oreille moyenne c'est-à-dire les trois
eau dont il parle tout à l'heure mais
dont c'était extrêmement confus parce
qu'il comprend rien ce qu'
dit les trois EOS moyens de dont il a
parlé c'est les EOS de l'oreille Mo
euh ce qui ce qui en étant charitable
correspond à
auanique au marteau et à l'enclume en
étant charitable parce que généralement
le le paniic n'est pas considéré comme
un un os de l'oreille moyenne c'est le
stapè donc l'étrier qui est considéré
comme un os de l'oreille moyenne mais
l'étrier est d'origine crâenne il est
pas d'origine mandibulaire donc c'est il
ne comprend rien à ce qu'il dit voyez il
ne comprend pas il ne sait pas ce qu'il
raconte parce qu'il a copiécollé son
discours d'un discours créationniste sur
HWS in Genesis et je vous rappelle que
HW in Genesis c'est c'est c'est le c'est
c'est nul c'est nul l'évolution des
ailes des reptile en est une autre pure
impossibilité car la structure des
reptiles terrestres et des oiseaux
vivants dans l'air sont bien trop
différents et mèent aussitôt à la
complexité irréductible c'est c'est
c'est tellement impossible d'avoir une
main de dinosaure qui évolue ensuite en
aile d'oiseau que c'est exactement ce
que fait
l'adsine durant sa durant son
développement c'est c'est tellement
impossible que regardez je tape oatsine
je suis même je suis même sûr de pas
avoir à taper le bras de l'azin la arme
oazzin parce que je suis sûr que c'est
le premier truc qui va sortir BIM
badabou la fameuse la main de l'atsine
quand il est bébé la main de l'atine
quand il est adulte ceci est la
structure typique d'e Nile ceci est la
structure typique d'une main de
dinosaure théropode avec des bonnes
grosses griffes des bonnes gros bon gros
doigts bien développés bien
séparés c'est tellement impossible que
les oazines le font en une vie voilà
c'est tellement impossible de le faire
en plusieurs millions d'années que les
oazin le font pendant leur vie c'est
voilà on est à ce niveau là d'
possibilité voyez nous avonsf tout à
l'heure un évolutionniste admet le
problème des ailes qui sont présentes
dans la théorie
Darwin a et ne peuvent fonctionner que
si sont pleinement développés en d'ut
TER un développé ne peut pas
voir pas vol la façes organes on jour
des mystè de la nature qui do être écl
est-ce qu'il va partir sur l'œil
vraiment l'argument de l'œil bah c'est
un argument de complexité irréductible
donc en plus il tourne en rond et
l'argument de l'œil bah c'est un
argument typique hein de de de la de la
complexité pétée hein de de de la
fameuse complexité pétée de la
complexité inutile ou de la complexité
inélégante puisque l'œil humain
typiquement les les récepteurs sont
montés à l'envers donc vous avez le
câble qui rend vous avez le récep qui
est tourné vers votre cerveau ou vers
l'os du crâne comme vous préférez et le
câble qui est tourné vers l'intérieur de
l'œil pareil programme de lycée donc
l'œil humain c'est typiquement encore
une fois un
exemple de si ça a été inventé
intelligemment enfin que si un ingénieur
devait se pencher sur la question il
dirait mais vous êtes con mettez les
récepteurs à l'endroit les récepteur
vers la lumière le câble tourn vers le
cerveau bande de cons donc on est
typiquement devant un exemple bah de de
de de design pété quoi de un exemple de
grosse cicatrice de l'évolution et qu'en
l'occurrence l'œil se forme à partir
d'un repli et que ce repli bah par
définition a foutu l'œil à l'envers en
fait donc il y a a il y a un défaut
fondamental dans la façon dont s'est
formé l'œil au cours de l'évolution qui
a été
conservé et c'est cette et c'est ça qui
crée cette fameuse complexité
inélégante qui est une cicatrice de
l'évolution on n pas trouvé de forme de
transition mais justement une survenue
soudaine d'animaux nouveaux lorsqu'on
observe les couches géologiques on a
découvert contrairement à ce qu'affirme
les darwiniens que dans un las de temps
très court il y a eu soudainement une
profusion de vie de toutes sortes cet
événement merveilleux est appelé
l'explosion cambrienne en fait dans les
gouches du pré Cambrien la vie semble
naître sans longue évolution sans
transformation d'espèces ce qui est pour
le coup démontré par les fossiles
contenus dans les formations géologiques
et qui ne présent aucune forme
transitoire la plupart des formes de vie
trouvées dans les couches cambrienes
présent des systèmes d'organes qui
apparaissent très soudainement comme les
yeux les branchies et d'autres
structures très développées et qui ne se
distinguent en aucun cas de leur
appareil moderne il est important
constater que les genes animaux présents
au époque cambrienne précoce se
distinguent autant l'un de l'autre
qu'ils ne le font aujourd'hui en fait si
la diversité des espèces aurait dû se
développer comme les ramifications d'un
arbre issu d'un seul frond comme selon
Darwin on observe au contraire que les
ligées singulières apparaissent
parallèles plusieurs défauts dans cette
dans ce raisonnement je commence à être
en état d'abandon total plusieurs défaut
dans ce raisonnement le premier bah
c'est encore une fois tout part du
principe que le registre fossile devrait
être complet orors il ne l'est pas
deuxièmement ce qu'on constate au
Cambrien c'est un biais de préservation
c'estàdire il dit les organes
apparaissent genre il dit les branchis
les machins les yeux tout ça tout
apparaît d'un coup de très très
soudainement mais pourquoi est-ce que
tout apparaît d'un coup bah parce que
soudainement on a deux billets de
fossilisation qui rentrent en jeu d'une
part il y a l'apparition de de la
coquille donc soudainement la pression
de prédation est devenue plus importante
au
Cambrien il y a eu plus de prédateurs on
ne sait pas pourquoi mais il y a
certainement eu plus de prédateur donc
la nécessité d'évoluer une coquille un
squelette est devenu plus importante et
donc on a soudainement au Cambri
une course aux armements vers la
formation d'un
squelette donc de d'une part il y a
l'apparition des squelettes qui le le la
présence de squelettes se généralise dû
à cette course aux armements et de fait
on a un billet de fossilisation qui qui
rentre en jeu à savoir bah d'un seul
coup on a des squelettes donc on a
beaucoup de trucs qui se préservent d'un
seul coup et de deux et ben il y a Sheng
Jang et Burgess qui sont deux sites
seulement deux sites où la préservation
est [__] d'exceptionnel et où on voit
les organes mou et donc avant ça on
n'est pas capable de les voir dans le
registre fossile parce qu'il y a pas de
squelette et que de toute façon il y a
pas d'organes mou préservé dans le
registre fossile et soudainement on est
capable de préserver les organes mous
donc les branchis les yeux les les
cerveaux et cetera et cetera c'est
magnifique c'est très bien qu'on ait ça
mais dans l'absolu il faudrait qu'on ait
ça avant pour pouvoir être sûr que
l'affirmation qu'il est en train de dire
est correcte or on a pas ça avant donc
ce qu'il est en train de décrire c'est
un biais du registre fossile plus qu'un
véritable phénomène évolutif donc il y a
pas grand-chose à débunquer à ce
niveau-là c'est juste un un énorme
billet du registre fossile qui est très
bien mise en avant par la phylogénie que
lui-même nous montre ici euh puisque là
donc ce que enfin je suppose parce que
évidemment il y a pas la légende mais là
en gros vous avez les points qui
correspondent au premier fossile et vous
avez les branches qui s'enfoncent
beaucoup plus profondément ce qu'on
appelle des lignées fantômes lignées
fantômes que l'ADN donc par horloge
moléculaire permet de calculer donc
quand vous ajoutez l'ADN à la
connaissance en plus des fossiles hein
ce que les créationnistes tâchent le
plus de d'ignorer parce que l'ADN ça les
emmerde parce que l'ADN ne ment
pas et donc quand on arrête d'ignorer
l'ADN bah on regarde l'horloge
moléculaire c'est-à-dire qu'en fonction
des taux de mutation on arrive à
reconstituer à quel point une lignée est
ancienne puisque si on a si on a la si
on a le la vitesse à laquelle ils
évoluent et qu'on sait la distance
évolutive qui a été parcourue donc le
nombre de mutation donc on a le nombre
de mutations et on a la vitesse à
laquelle ils évoluent donc donc on a la
distance et la vitesse et ben on peut
savoir depuis combien de temps ils ont
divergé ils ont divergé donc on peut on
peut reconstituer à quel point à quel
moment une lignée a pu apparaître et
donc ce qu'on constate avec les animaux
de burgesse c'est que quand on les
compare quand on les replace sur une
philogénie avec leurs descendants
modernes parce que certains des animaux
de Burgess ont des descendants modernes
bah on constate que avant Burgess il y a
eu une immense lignée fantôme donc les
lignées fantôme c'est avant les points
enfin du moins si si je lis correctement
son graphe parce qu' évidemment il a pas
mis de légende à son graphe alors on
peut faire un peu ce qu'on veut donc euh
donc ça l'ADN est la preuve que ce qu'on
observe à
burgesss c'est juste un billet de
fossilisation enfin le résultat des deux
billets de fossilisation dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure c'est pas un
phénomène réel ce n'est pas apparu
soudainement comme de jeunes plans
distribués en série sans racine c'est
comme si elles y avaient été simplement
planté sans préistoire évolutif dans le
magazine scientifique Science on
confirme le début de l'époque cambrienne
connu la survenue soudaine de presque
tous les regroupements principaux des
animaux à tester dans les fossiles qui
constituent jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore
de façon prédominante les biotas d'près
ce que dit char Darwin l'explosion C
avec les organes émergents soudain ah on
va reciter Charles Darwin et comme
planifié d'intérieur devrait avoir sonné
la fin de son hypothèse car il a
lui-même écrit si l'on pouvait mettre en
évidence un quelconque organe composé
dont l'achèvement aurait pu ne pas être
produit par de petites modifications
successives ma théorie ne pourrait que
s'effondrer de nombreuses facettes de la
nature sont bien ça a rien à voir avec
l'explosion cambrienne ce qu' vient de
dire Charles Darwin a effectivement
parlé de l'explosion cambrienne comme
une des faiblesses de sa
théorie mais c'est pas cette citation
là faut vraiment lui dire tout ce qu'il
a à dire là ce qu'il vient de dire ce
qu'il vient de dire c'est un argument
pour la complexité
irréductible c'est nul à ce pointl
mesdames et messieurs c'est nul à ce
point c'est nul au point où où je où il
faut le corriger quoi travons tous
ensemble avec cerveau produisant
imagesti sur l' est un exemple F de
compleité irducti fait nombre et on est
reparti donc et il admet complètement
être reparti sur la complexité
irréductible c'estàd qu'il admet être
hors sujet dans son propre
chapitrage pe avoir été formé par la
section naturelle semble je le confesse
volontiers absurde au plus haut deg nous
avons vu que Charles Darwin 1860 pareil
on on a quand même pas mal progressé
depuis je vais pas revenir sur l'exemple
de l'œil j'ai déjà dit pourquoi c'était
un exemple non pas de complexité
irréductible mais au contraire de
complexité
absurde donc je revi
pas pas de conna anim c'estd la forme
visage la peau les yeux la queue la
chair ou les organes en plus de ça même
l'anatomie et la biomécanique de
l'animal sont souvent ininterprétabl car
car les fossiles sont incomplets et les
E en grande partie cass ah bon bah
maintenant maintenant les fossiles sont
incomplets en fait dans T les les belles
images tu sais qu'on va présenter dans
les magazines sur et cetera on va
commencer à te mettre une queue qui
s'allonge sauf qu'en fait bah si tu
regardes le vrai fossile là T qui est
présenté en fait il y a pas de queue il
y a pas de queue et quand tu vas
demander au découvreur ce qu'il en pense
il dit ah B j'ai pensé qu'il avait une
queue j'ai interprété j'ai j'ai pensé
que il pourrait avoir une queue par ça
pourit P de La Valette et pareil pour
membr palmés il dit ah bah ouais B j'ai
inféré fait qu' av repalmer pu qu'en
fait ils ont trouvé un autre Foss il se
ru compte qu' av pas les repalmer il
avit pas que à manger comme ça alors sur
la SL d'après donc il dit lui-même il
dit je traduit l'anglais j'ai spéculé
que ça pourrait avoir que la noire
codale de la bine à l'arrière là donc
j'ai j'ai spéculé que ça pourrait avoir
uneal je doute maintenant que le
rodocetus avait une une queue allongée
voilà donc le symbole de l'évolution
enend pour pour son gr et donc en fait
ça à gauche c'est donc en fait ce qu'on
va présenter dans les magazines on va
dire bah regardez l'ambulocus il
ressemblait à ça et ça ma allonger et
puis à droite bah c'est le vra qu'on l'
retrouvé sauf qu'en fait çaemble pas du
tout entre à droite à gauche oui il
manque des portions d'os sauf qu'en fait
c'est complèt ement infér au niveau de
la taille Lao très beaucoup plus courte
mais au niveau des narines en fait on
sait pas du tout où les ét donc voilà
c'est très complexe c'estàd que là les
fossiles ça be sur plein de trucs très
complexes ça va être les temps ça va
être des articulations ça va être
comment dire tout un tas de trucs
vraiment je me suis pris la tête en
anatomie c'est très très complexe je
juste des exemples mais c'est un peu
pour illustrer le fait que des fois
quand on dit quelque chose c'est pas
forcément vrai parquo alors les fis
c'est trop compliqué parce qu'il y a des
dents par tout ça et puis c'est très
très complexe et puis vraiment je me
suis cassé la tête non tu t'es pas cassé
la tête parce que tu tu as même pas
essayé de comprendre le jus la sève là
il est en train en gros ce qu'il est en
train de dire c'est les artistes quand
ils redessinent des animaux à partir des
des fossiles et ben ils inventent des
trucs ils inventent les partisoles waouh
noit
Sherlock tu es vraiment en train d'être
tu as vraiment l'impression d'être en
train de révolutionner le champ de
recherche en disant des choses comme ça
là parce que vraiment c'est c'est
pathétiique c'est
pitoyable donc ce qui relie rodocetus ce
qui relie rodocetus et vous allez voir
ma vidéo l'évolution des CAC comme
j'aurais voulu qu'on me l'explique c'est
une vidéo courte qui résume l'histoire
des sciences en matière d'évolution des
CAC et qui résume aussi notre
compréhension l'évolution de la
compréhension de l'évolution des CAC et
en gros ce qui lit les cac comme
rodocetus à nos CAC modernes c'est les
dents donc évidemment si on regarde les
dents et qu'on dit mais non mais
attendez les dents moi c'est trop
compliqué je comprends pas j'ai pas
envie de savoir bah évidemment que on va
passer à côté du message
parce que c'est les dents la clé est
dans les dents les dents et l'oreille
donc c'est au niveau des dents et de
l'oreille que ça va se passer c'est les
oreilles donc qui chez les cétacés sont
paiostotiques donc il sont fait d'os
très dens et très épais c'est ces
oreilles là qu'on retrouve aussi chez
les cassé moderne qu'on retrouve chez
rodocetus embulocetus et jusqu'à indoius
dans le l'Éocène inférieur et les dents
les grosses dents triangulair avec des
pointes qui vont aussi tracer une ligne
continue depuis pquicetus Ambulocetus R
CUS jusqu'à basilosaurus jusqu'à
squalodon squalodon qui a tout d'un
dauphin moderne à part les grosses dents
triangulaires mais les grosses dents
triangulaires il y a encore un dauphin
moderne chez qui on les retrouve c'est
le dauphin du Gange donc il y a il y a
une ligne comme ça il y a des il y a des
fils rouges qui sont étendus depuis ces
ancêtres des cétacés là qu'on voit là
jusqu'au cétacé modne il y a des
caractères qui sont en commun et ces
caractères en commun sont les caractères
qui nous disent voilà pourquoi on pense
que rodocetus est ambul CUS sont
dessétacés et évidemment he s'il
s'arrête pas sur les détails comme les
dents alors que les dents c'est le cœur
de la paléomamalogie donc ignorer les
dents c'est comme c'est comme vouloir
faire de l'astronomie sans regarder vers
le haut quoi c'est c'est c'est juste
inconcevable en fait de de parler
d'évolution des mammifères sans regarder
les dents mais c'est littéralement faire
de l'astronomie sans jamais regarder
vers le ciel quoi c'est je fais de
l'astronomie voilà je regarde par là et
et et je vois rien donc vous êtes des
nuls les astronomes nous montent c'est
nul c'est nul je vois pas je vois rien
là je les vois pas vos
galaxies on en est là on en est là donc
rodocetus ses dents son oreille son
oreille moyenne sont préservés sur le
matériel qu'on a hein voilà c'est ici
tout est là le crâne est complet donc
l'oreille moyenne avec le tympanique
épais et les dents sont préservées et
sont les mêmes que chez squalodon les
mêmes que chez le plataniste donc le
dauphin du Gange et on a cette colonne
vertébrale qui relie le crâne jusqu'au
bassin ici bassin avec un fémur qui nous
indique que rodocetus avait au moins
deux pattes à l'arrière ce que les
dauphin modne nont pas et donc qu'il et
donc bah il a évolué point barre point à
la ligne et là encore je je vous fais je
vous fais grâce de la logique
élémentaire du il avait des pattes
arrière il avait des pattes avant hein
bon je veux dire on va pas on va pas se
mettre à remettre des choses aussi
évidentes que ça en question donc
rodocetus c'était un C assé à quatre
pattes mais faut regarder les bons
caractères faut pas regarder les
reconstitutions de Paléo artist les
reconstitution de paléoartiste c'est
juste fait pour rendre la chose jolie et
présentable au
public c'est pas ça les données
scientifiques et quand on critique la
théorie de l'évolution le moindre chose
ce serait quand même de critiquer les
données scientifiques jeeten
je veux dire c'est comme si vous
critiquiez
le le trou noir dans
interstellar ah le trou noir dans
interstellar il est pas réaliste voilà
donc les astronomes nous ment le
tyrannosaure il ressemblait pas au
tyrannosaur de Jurassic Park donc les
paléontologues
nous bon et puis après comme j'ai dit je
vous fait grâce aussi de la logique de
tout à l'heure le registre fossile était
suffisamment bien complet pour prés les
interéires et maintenant le registre
fossile finalement il est pas très il
est pas complet du tout du coup on peut
rien dire sur
l'évolution donc là il y a a pirouette
triple salto arrière de
[Musique]
logique
diffiseis aptor ah oui c'est qui revendu
sa plus une fort et en fa c'était unage
de différ
pour ça c'est bien pour une fois on nous
parle de l'archéoraptor plutôt que de
nous parler
de nous parler de l'homme de
P donc l'archoraptor était effectivement
un faux qui a été notoirement
reconnu et donc l'archéoraptor a été non
pas publié dans une revue scientifique
mais dans en National géographique
contrairement à ce qu'il dit euh
l'archéoraptor a été pour la première
fois publié dans une revue scientifique
en 2005 et en 2006 il a été débunké non
pas par des créationnistes mais par
Timothy RAW Timothy RAW qui est un
paléontologue évolutionniste tout ce qu'
y a de plus normal donc en fait quand il
y a des faux ça fait chier les
paléontologues bien plus que n'importe
qui d'autre les paléontologues ne
fabriquent pas des faux pour soutenir la
théorie de l'évolution les
paléantologues quand il voient des faux
il les pointe du Doig en disant ça c'est
un
faux le faux en l'occurrence
archéoraptor c'est un fossile chinois
les fossiles chinois qui ont été acheté
hein comme il le dit très bien ça
l'information est correcte ce fossile
chinois qui a été acheté certainement à
un fermier en Chine euh sont notoirement
connu pour pour beaucoup être décollage
donc oui l'erreur ça a été d'acheter un
fossile chinois parce que les les les
les les fermiers chinois ils collent des
fossiles ensemble pour les rendre plus
beaux donc s'il trouve une pte parci un
corps par là une tête par là bah ils les
colle ensemble et puis ça fait un
squelette complet et ça ils le vendent
plus cher mais c'est pas les
paléontologues qui ont fait le collage
c'est des c'est le fermier chinois ou
alors le le mec qui a acheté des
fossiles en vraque au fermier chinois et
qui a ensuite voulu faire un profit en
les colant ensemble pour faire des beaux
squelettes mais c'est pas les
paléontologues qui ont fait le collage
donc le faux n'a pas été fait par des
paléontologues euh les paléontologues
l'ont subi et se sont très vite dépêché
de le débunker quand ils se sont rendus
compte de la percherie ça a pris que un
an donc en réalité moi pour moi c'est
une histoire à mettre au crédit des
évolutionnistes pour une honnêteté
intellectuelle honnêteté intellectuelle
dont j'espère que vous aurez pu le
remarquer les créationnistes ne font pas
vraiment preuve quand il s'agit
d'utiliser des arguments qui ont été
débunkés depuis les années 70
ah on retrouve lorsqu'ils sont présentés
entier dans les études les magazines les
documentaires sont souvent des
reconstitutions hypothétiques cela nous
mène au fait qu'il faut être extrêmement
prudent face à toute cette
information
th maîre maître madame
garison on est bien d'accord que la
scène de Madame Garrison c'est une
parodie des créationnistes pas une
parodie des évolutionnistes faut
vraiment
être complètement à côté de la plaque
pour s'imaginer que Madame Garrison dans
cette
scène parodie la théorie de l'évolution
ce n'est pas ça qui est parodié c'est
une parodie de créationniste là
quicissit c'est Madame garison qui est
créationniste qui refuse de croire en la
théorie de l'évolution et qui du coup la
présente d'une façon complètement
absurde c'est une parodie de
créationniste madame
gonosaur VO dans les
sontz les dinosaures sont faux on va
partir sur la théorie des dinosaures
sont faux juste pour compléter sur ce
qu'il dit sur les reconstitution si vous
retrouvez une dent isolé il n'est pas
déraisonnable de faire l'hypothèse que
cette dent était accrochée à une
mâchoire que cette mâchoire si elle
était supérieure était elle- même
accrochée à une mâchoire inférieure que
ces deux mâchoires étaient accroché à un
crâne et que ce crâne était accroché à
un corps corps qui avait
potentiellement des côtes des vertèbres
quatre pattes
bref c'est quoi exactement qu'on
critique quand on montre ça c'est quoi
exactement qui est critiqué quand on
montre ça et qu'on dit comment ils ont
fait pour savoir que ça appartener à un
animal comme ça c'est quoi exactement
qui est critiqué là c'est vous avez
vraiment envisagé la possibilité de
qu'une griffe se baladait toute seule
comme ça avec ses petits pieds à elle
vous avez vraiment envisagé la
possibilité que les dents elles se
promenaient comme ça les dents de
dinosaur se promène comme ça toute seule
par elle-même comme
ça je vais tout mer je vais te
mer c'est quoi qu'on critique
exactement
moi je sais pas je demande je fais que
poser des
questions pas produit dans des usine des
dinosaures oh là là ce sont des moulages
des répliques au pire ce sont des
composites c'estàdire des on a pris des
réplique de plusieurs morceaux de
squelett de la même espèce qu'on a
assemblé ensemble pour faire un
squelette plus complet parce que c'est
plus joli à montrer dans les musées
voilà parce que vous montrez les râons
qu'on trouve effectivement les gens
comprennent pas ce qu'on leur montre
donc on leur montre matériau qui est
déjà qui a déjà subi une phase
d'interprétation effectivement on leur
montre du matériel qui a déjà subi des
phases
d'interprétation donc c'est pas les
données brutes qu'on montre dans les
musées parce que si on vous montrer les
données brutes dans les musées bah
effectivement il faudrait que quelqu'un
se tienne à côté pour vous expliquer ce
qu'on voit parce que c'est compliqué
d'expliquer ce qu'on voit donc oui les
les musées faut pas oublier que les
musées sont des structures de
communication
scientifique alors après dans les
collections vous vous pourrez avoir
accès au vrai matériel encore faut-il
avoir la dessence de d'en demander
l'accès autant plutôt que de les accuser
tout de suite de vous montrer des choses
complètement fausses et complètement
inventées il faut évidemment avoir
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de faire la
démarche de demander l'accès à ses
données àes à ces collections où le vrai
matériel est en stockage mais ça
l'honnêteté intellectuelle généralement
chez les créationnistes ça brille pas
c'est pas ça qu'on voit c'est TR complet
cassé donc souvent exploitable il l dans
des caisses à l'abri des regards mais
imaginez simplementabri des regards il
nous montre un magnifique crâne de de
dinosaur en pluset casséentexoitable il
log dans des caisses à ça c'est pas
inexploitable regardez c'est très bien
interprété c'est très bien en plus c'est
sorti d'une publication scientifique
puisque il y a des voyez qu'il y a
des dire c'est c'est y a les petits il y
a les petits labels là c'est c'est anoté
c'est c'est bien présenté c'est organisé
ABCD tout
ça c'est pas inexploitable vu que ça là
c'est typiquement c'est de l'os qui a
été exploité et puis on sait très bien
d'où ça vient regardez ça ça ça ça
appartient à tel morceau ça ça
appartient des morceau ça c'est un
morceau de la mâchoire tout va bien tout
va bien avec ça mais imaginez simplement
le nombre de personnes qui visitent le
musée en croyant apercevoir d'authentiqu
squelettes de dinosaures alors que c'est
tout simplement pas le cas
bah ça si si les gens arrêtent de piquer
les morceaux des des squelettes aussi
quand on leur met des vrais squelettes
pour les revendre ensuite sur ebay on
montrerait des vrais squelettes mais bon
l'histoire a démontré que c'est c'est
pas ça c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
j'ai appris l'autre jour qu'il y avait
un mammouth
entier qui était qui était dans un musée
à Yakutsk je crois en Russie et genre il
y a des mecs qui ont démonté le mamouth
entier pour le
revendre c'est c'est vous dire à quel
point on en
est plus plus près de chez nous il y
avait le le squelette de l'éléphant de
Louis XIV dont ils ont coupé
une c'est caricain c'est lesadi bah
lesadi je peux vous dire qu'il est réel
puisque j'ai vu les EOS moi-même hein en
plus je les ai déjà montré sur la chaîne
donc il y a aucune excuse les Doua a dit
c'est du vrai alors oui ça c'est une
reconstitution qui a été fait par mon
collègue Victor radermarker qui est à la
fois chercheur et paléoartiste donc très
très doué comme vous pouvez le voir mais
bon benah encore une fois je veux dire
si ça pour vous c'est de la
science-fiction je veux dire il va
falloir m'expliquer comment pour vous
une vertèbre comme celle-là qui est
définitivement une vertèbre au-delà de
tout un interprétation possible comment
est-ce qu'une vertèbre comme ça se
promenait toute seule sans aucun sans
aucune colonne vertébrale pour attacher
dessus dire Victor lui il a fait que
l'hypothèse enfin c'est même pas Victor
Victor il est c'est il a effectivement
dessiné ça mais c'est pas lui qui l'a
étudié mais bref Victor il ici dans son
dessin il n'a fait que l'hypothèse que
la vertèbre était l'hypothèse
raisonnable que cette vertèbre était
attachée à un animal qui était
invertébré de l'ordre des tétrapodes et
donc qui avait quatre
pattes il s'agit toujours de
reconstitution et
d'hypothèse donc tout ça en fait ça par
articles si le commun des mortels était
capable d'interpréter les fossiles tels
quel on montrerait les fossiles
telsquels mais en l'occurrence ça prend
plusieurs années à apprendre à
interpréter un
fossile c'est bien pour ça qu'être
paléontologue c'est dur c'est compliqué
ça prend des années ça prend une thèse
et même quand tu as fini ta thèse tu es
encore pas suffisamment à l'aise tu as
encore besoin de post dooc et cetera
c'est c'est pour ça que ça prend super
longtemps de devenir paléontologue c'est
si tout le monde était capable moi
j'aimerais vivre dans un monde où tout
le monde serait capable d'interpréter
les fossiles quand je leur montre un
truc je leur dis bah oui là tu vois
c'est c'est super intéressant et j'ai
pas j'ai même pas expliqué ce qu'il y a
à avoir je leur tends le fossile en
disant tu vois c'est super intéressant
ah mais oui exactement je vois
exactement ce que tu veux dire il y a ça
il y a ça il y a ça il y a ça il y a ça
mais on vit pas dans un monde comme ça
on vit dans un monde où pour comprendre
les fossiles faut se spécialiser et on
vit dans un monde où pour comprendre
comment un ordinateur ou une télé
fonctionne il faut se spécialiser et que
généralement on peut pas être
spécialiste de l'un de l'autre et de
tout le reste en même temps donc oui le
la personne qui m'explique comment ma
télé fonctionne va falloir qu'elle
prenne quelques minutes voire quelques
heures pour m'expliquer comment ça
marche la personne qui répare ma voiture
il va falloir qu'elle prenne quelques
heures voir quelques ou alors que juste
qu'elle le répare et qu'elle m'explique
vaguement ce qui ce qu'elle a fait et
puis bah je dirais oui oui ok pas de
souci je ve dire c'est c'est comme
accuser ton garagiste de de de de je
sais pas je je comprends pas en fait la
logique du truc c'est dire vous avez
montré les garagistes font même pas cet
effort là d'ailleurs en réalité j'allais
dire j'allais faire une analogie avec
les garagistes mais en réalité les
garagistes ils font même pas cette cet
effort de vulgarisation là il répare ta
voiture et
basta tu veux le le c'est le service
marketing du garage après qui va te
faire une publicité où en 2 minutes on
va te résumer les choses vachement bien
qu'on fait dans le
garage mais évidemment si tu dis en
regardant la publicité c'est pas ça que
les garagistes font c'est un
mensonge bah le garagiste il va te
regarder et puis il va faire non mais tu
te sens bien ça va bah si tu veux pas
que je te la réparte TA voiture
casse-toi c'est voilà ce qui va se
passer mais c'est pas la faute c'est pas
la faute au garagiste c'est la fauto
service marketing bon bah là c'est
pareil c'est c'est un c'est un biais
inhérent à la muséologie si vous voulez
c'est un BIA inhérent au fait de vouloir
faire de la vulgarisation c'est oui il
faut simplifier oui il faut rendre les
choses jolies attractives et facile à
interpréter sinon sinon sinon c'est la
merde mais là c'est encore une fois ce
qui critique c'est pas les données
scientifiques brutes ce qui cri c'est
juste la façon dont elles sont
présentées mais c'est pas du travail de
fond ça ma bonne dame c'est du c'est du
tourisme pour dire dans le plus grand
décalme qu'en fait un/ers des dinosaures
n'existerait
pas et bien mon très cher jeani c'est
une sortie de route une complète sortie
de route qui n qui nous dévaste
complètement le sujet a été complètement
perdu on ne sait plus de quoi on parle
on raconte de la merde on fait du de la
sortie de c'est c'est de la sortie de
pas de la sortie de route de la sortie
de contexte mais alors un tiers des
dinosaures n'aurait jamais existé pardon
je répète un tiers des espèces de
dinosaures n'aurait jamais existé un/ers
des dinosaures seraiit des synonymes
d'espèces déjà
existantes
c'est c'est c'est si vous voulez c'est
c'est c'est dire que un/ers des
dinosaures n'auraiit jamais existé ça
veut dire que que les deux tiers que ce
tiers de dinosaures c'est des mensonges
non c'est juste que on leur a pas donné
le bon nom c'est tout c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça par pitié ne pars pas là-dedans par
pitié ne par pas là-dedans si tu veux
conserver un minimum de crédibilité
sérieusement les s'il part là-dedans
s'il part dans l'idée ouais les
dinosaures existent pas la preuve il y
en a qui ont changé de nom hein genre le
bronosaur genre le bronthosaurus
n'existait pas en fait oui le
bronthosaurus n'existait pas parce qu'on
l'a mis en synonymie avec apatosaur
Apatosaurus bon ceci étant dit on a
ressuscité bronthosaurus en 2014 mais
bref mais non c'est c'est juste non il y
a un tiers des dinosaures pour lequel le
nom d'espèce ne serait pas valide ça
veut pas dire que le fossile existe pas
c'est juste qu'on leur a pas donné le
bon nom le on aura pas donné le bon nom
d'espèces donc par pitié si tu veux
conserver un minimum de crédibilité et
pour les gens qui m'ont envoyé ta vidéo
en me faisant croire que ça allare une
vidéo intelligente par pitié ne va pas
là-dedans je te laisse une chance ne me
déçois pas se serait trompé sur toutes
les espèces de dinosaures connus une sur
TR serait une illusion alors non cette
information ne convient pas de compl
magazine mais ça est bien la conclusion
à laquelle on abouti le C bah oui he
c'est ça un tiers des espèces connues de
dinosaures il s'agirait de stades
différents de développement de ses
animaux pour un paléentologue John Jack
Horner qui est l'auteur de quelquesunes
des plus importantes découvertes
récentes de rest de dinosaure et de son
collègue Mark B Goodwin des différences
morphologiques marquées entre jeunes et
adultes auraient indu en erreur les
paléontologues mais par contre les les
jeunes dinosaures ils existent he ils
existent les espèces de jeunes
dinosaures ça veut pas dire qu'ils
existent pas les fossiles ils existent
c'est juste qu'ils ont pas on leur a pas
donné le bon nom comme lui ce qu'il
avait proposé c'était stigimolo et
stegoeras qui serait en fait des
juvéniles de pquicéphalosur mais les
faossiles ils
existent comprend facilement ce
comportement par le fait qu'ils vivent
littéralement leurs travaux et qu'ils
souitent tous faire carrière en plus de
cela ils sont complètement souten par la
société qui posune ce soit au niveau
éique à [__] les recherche
les pas com mal plusie il loy le mot
connerie ça y est attends il a employé
le mot connerie ça veut dire que j'ai le
droit d'être vulgaire c'est bon c'est
parti 2014 sur tour qui apporte ses
connaissan pour la conception d'une
espèce fictive de
dinosauropodindominus Rex spécialement
imaginé pour l'occasion
imagine un film Maor [__] ave
desésentation erré mal voir carrément
mensongère on comprend facilement ce
comportement par le fait qu'ils vivent
littéralement de leurs travaux et qu'ils
souhaitent tous faire carrière en plus
de cela ils sont complètement soutenus
par la société qui ne se pose aucune
question que ce soit au niveau
idéologique à travers oui c'est à
travail donc on vine nos travaux oui
ceci étant dit on n'est pas payé à la
publication
donc on sera pas payé plus cher parce
qu'on publiera plus de dinosaures enfin
plus de nouvelles espèces de dinosaures
donc je sais pas encore une fois il
s'est pas renseigné sur le truc qu'il
critique ce qui est un symptôme majeur
des de recherche les musé le monde du C
ra toujours plus dans la connerie on a
plusieurs cas de palologu qui ont fait
scandale en ayant tenté de constituer
des fossiles euxmêm par assemblage de
rest de divers animaux à nouveau pour
faire carrière par exemple l'araptor est
l'aroraptor avait été assemblé par les
fermiers et ou les vendeurs pas par les
paléontologues venant de Chine dans un
article publié dans le magazine National
Geographic en 1999 l'article du magazine
ind que le était une forme
transitionnelle entre ce étant dit on
notera quand même que dans la
catégorie
fake mieux que de répéter aroraptor de
fois donc pareil j'attire votre
attention sur le fait queil a pas mieux
que ça en
faits50 années la question du singe et
l'homme dit-il avec un
touamp transanné à thé SAV la taille Dr
une transition d'un million d'années du
singe à l'homme pardon 10 million
d'années tu veux dire parce que 1
million d'années non il y a un million
d'années c'était déjà homoctus mais bien
tapé donc un truc que tu aurais eu
vraiment du mal à pas appeler un être
humain il y a environ 4 millions
d'années à la suite de transformation
climatique du fait de la disparition de
l'offre 4 millions d'années c'est
australopycus mec tu es loin tu es loin
de nourriture la population des primates
s'est trouvé sous pression si bien que
quelques individus hardis ont cherché en
dehors de ces forêts de nourriture dans
la savane ils sont sortis pour aller
dans les plaines couvertes d'Erb de
l'Afrique la sélection naturelle est
alors c on est un mec on est face à un
mec qui est en train de nous critiquer
les scénarios de enfin les scénarios les
hypo de l'évolution de humaine alors
qu'il est même pas au courant que sa
elanthropus a été découvert quoi je veux
dire un francophone qui est pas au
courant que Sahelanthropus à 7 millions
d'années quoi
ou aurorine même je veux dire ce qui est
pas au courant de saanthropus et
hororin à quel point faut avoir rien lu
sur le sujet à quel point faut même pas
avoir regarder
Wikipédia même pas regarder Wikipédia
propriété humaine moderne de se révéler
avantageuse alors que ces caractères se
développai lentement selon l'évolution
l'homme se serait drressé sur C jambes
arrièr pour pouvoir regarder auudessus
de l'herbe haute en même temps que le
CER et allez on te regarde la West Side
Story enfin la East Side Story comme si
c'était une théorie encore acceptée
aujourd'hui rien à voir avec aucun des
autres êtres vivants sur terre c'est à
cause des
voilàir prièr comme nous abordé
précédment cette
th East Side stor a été proposé par
CIN je dis propos ça a été popularisé
par copins dans les années 80 au début
des années
80 début des années 80 il te sort une
théorie qui date du début des années 80
et l'existence de saahelanthropus et de
hororine enfin surtout selanthropus en
l'occurrence l'existence de
Sahelanthropus et
d'australopythque en dehors du rift
africain a montré que cette théorie à
défaut d'être complètement fausse était
en tout cas très très très très
incomplète donc là le monsieur il
s'apprête à nous débuner un truc que
plus personne ne croit en
réalité c'est c'est bien parce que c'est
même plus un homme de paille en fait à
ce niveau-là c'est même plus une
stratégie de on construit une théorie
fausse et on va défoncer la théorie
fausse parce qu'elle est fausse c'est on
va prendre une théorie qui est déjà
obsolète et on va pointer du doigt
qu'elle est obsolète sachant que c'est
est déjà les paléontologues eu mêmes qui
ont fait le travail de pointer de
pointage de doigts c'est prodigieux
c'est prodigieux mais alors là s'il
croit vraiment être en train de
réinventer la c la poudre à couper l'eau
chaude il se trompe lourd de Ming
l'existence de la macroévolution c'estàd
la formation d'espèces nouvelles m
d'innovation phénotypique majeur mais
arrête avec la macroévolution tu sais
pas ce que ça veut dire arrête contra à
la microévolution Mme paration génétique
les animaux évoluent mais ne changent
pas radicalement d'espèces il est
impossible au qu'un jour un lézard ou un
singe même avec des millions d'années de
sélection ne Devi un homme certes le
lard évoluera de manière à être plus
adapté dans son milieu par le fait que
leslément plus adaptés vont survivre et
se reproduire mais resteront toujours
dans la famille des reptiles
par parce que j'ai décidé que c'était le
cas et parce que ta gueule c'est magique
d'il avit uneelle seme
cisteespèces transitoir évoluant
graduellement jusqujourd'hui on observe
un imm entre l'homme et le reste ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que 600
différentes espèces ça fait longtemps
que tu as pas vu un chimpanz plus
intelligent que
toi concept
la fin du 19 siècle les
STIF en faisant l'hypothèseévolution
c'est bien parce qu'il vient de nous
dire il y a pas d'espèces transitoire en
nous montrant des espèce transitoire une
fois de plus hein de leur taille
correspondait à la ligne temporelle de
l'évolution jusqu'à atteindre l'homme
sauf que ce système de catégorisation de
la taille d'une espèce ne définit
évidemment en rien sa chronologie en
effet il existe une grande diversité
d'espèces de taillees différentes aux
mêmes
époques alors catégoriser la taille et
la taille du cerveau ça permet pas on
les a rangé en fonction de leur taille
et de leur taille de cerveau et puis ça
a fait une une séquence ça fait une
séquence évolutive ça aurait vraiment
été très très dommage si en remettant
ces espèces dans l'ordre chronologique
ça donne exactement la même histoire et
c'est ce qui nous montre à droite voilà
les espèces à petit cerveau sont en bas
les espèces à gros cerveau sont en haut
ça se voit très bien et de base en haut
c'est le temps en millions
d'années il est il est capable de vous
dire un truc et de vous montrer l'opposé
en même temps malgré ce premier problème
les scientifiques ont continué à de
l'homme qui le relie chronologiquement à
des espèces de plus en plus grandes que
ce soit au niveau de la taille du corps
et du crâne de plus les datation au
carbone 14 par l'étude des couches
géologiques des datations au carbone 14
alors qu'il nous montre une échelle de
temps en millions d'années tu vois le
mec est même pas allé voir sur Wikipédia
non plus le le champ d'applicabilité du
carbone 14 qui s'arrête à 50000 ans le
carbone 14 il s'arrête littéralement là
dans ton échelle chronologique là rien à
voir avec l'évolution
humaine un des journals les plus
importants en
science qui écr après coup eté en
conformité avec des préjugé humain et il
ajoute disposer une série de fail pu
affir qu'elle représente un arbre
généalogique n'est pas une hypothèse
scientifique qui pourrait être examiné
mais une faronade qui partage la même
revendication de réité hisire Al là ce
qu'il critiquait le monsieur c'était pas
l'évolution humaine c'était la
représentation linéaire de l'évolution
humaine encore une fois c'est une sortie
de c'est une sortie de contexte voit
sont plus
allir un peu plus ou moins proéinente et
par contre au niveau des E du cors on
voit ça se ressemble on va se dire bon
nickel on va pouvoir inférer en fait une
sorte d'évolution on va dire bon mon les
images d'A on va voir que ce crâne en
fait s'aplatir pour avoir une mâchoire
un petit peu plus carrée un petit peu
plus robuste qui sera untit peu plus
puissante cet autre crâne en fait lui va
per n montre des cllebs alors que le
chapitre est sur l'évolution
humaine on pas pe sujet CR hisire en
disant voilà ça s'est passé comme ça ça
a évolué comme ça pour t raison et en
fait T c crânessay de vous troller un
peu c'est les crân de chien c'est les CR
de chiens différents donc c'est il y a
un chien a essayer de nous troller
comment comment qu'on s'est fait avoir
tous on aurait pu monter de tout pi
hisire évu fait ils sont n mmep just des
CR de chien récent et donc ça c'est un
des problèmes en fait quand onou des
fossiles c'est que on peut vouloir créer
des histoires en fait au niveau des
fossile sur la base d'intuition et de
comparaison donc dans son schéma de
conceptualisation de l'évolution humaine
à lui il s'imagine que les crânes ont
été rangés dans l'ordre donc du plus
petit au plus gros C
et du plus long au du museau le plus
long au museau le plus court de façon
complètement
arbitraire si seulement on avait des
méthodes de
datation qui permettent de dater les
fossiles si seulement il existait des
méthodes de datation genre le potassium
argon
l'uranium le rubidium strontium le si
seulement il existait la
catodoluminescence la thermoluminescence
si seulement il existait 100 et une
façon de dater un
fossile qu'on a tous résumé dans cette
vidéo là les méthodes de datation avec
deux experts de la datation des fossiles
qui travaillent justement en Afrique de
l'Est donc qui travaill sur les fossiles
de la lignée humaine si seulement toutes
ces méthodes de datation ne permettaient
pas d'organiser ces fossiles du plus
ancien au plus récent de façon
complètement
objective ah si seulement si seulement
on avait si seulement on avait de telles
méthodes de datation si seulement ces
méthodes de datation existait à l'époque
où il avait sorti cette vidéo qui est
sortie il y a un an ah merde ma vidéo à
2 ans c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 2 ans on
vulgarisait la chose et en réalité je
peux vous assurer Mesdames et Messieurs
que ces méthodes de datation existent
depuis des dizaines d'années certaines
d'entre elles depuis même plus depuis 20
30 40 ans donc c'est ah
b
b histoire évolu fait on sait rien du
tout le truc c'est que si les darwi on
et le mec est tellement scientifique
qu'il a essayé de vous générer une
espèce d'histoire évolutive fake avec
ses crânes de chien mais il les a pas
tous mis dans la même vue ce qui fait
qu'en fait je sais pas si vous avez
réussi à comprendre où il voulait en
venir mais il a pas du tout réussi à il
a pas du tout réussi en fait il a échoué
contraire marale regardez l'être humain
est tellement différent du chimpanzé
qu'on a on a exactement tous les mêmes
EOS au mêmes endroits et surtout on a
les mêmes eau qui manquent au mêmes
endroits à savoir la queue hein à savoir
la fusion il y a deux eau du poignet qui
sont fusionné chez l'homme et le
chimpanzé et le Gori mais qui ne le sont
pas chez les autres singes donc pareil
il nous manque les mêmes EOS c'est pas
tellement les eos qui qui sont pareiles
mais que les eos qui sont pas pareils
qui qui sont importants donc il nous
manque la queue tous les deux il nous
manque un os au poignet tous les deux il
nous manque exactement le même nombre de
dents parce que normalement les
mammifères ont plus de prémolaire que ça
mais nous on a le même nombre de dents
bref c'est nos squelettes sont
rigoureusement identique à part pour la
posture et puis évidemment le certaines
proportions mais comme l'avait dit
Darwin à l'époque on diffère en degré
mais pas en
nature ceux qui croient en l'évolution
affirment que ce type de locomotion
s'est développé à partir du mouvement
sur quatre jambes un anatomiste le
professeur Robin cromton a montré en
1996 avec une simulation
tridimensionnelle sur l'ordinateur que
la bipédie ne peut pas provenir IR
évolutivement de la quadropédie ce
résultat contredit la test
traditionnelle l'titude supposée à
marcher de luci c'est tellement c'est
tellement impossible que même les
chimpanzés marche debout donc si ta
modélisation est pas capable de dire que
les chimpanzés devraient être capable
normalement de marcher sur sur deux
pattes bah c'est que la modélisation
elle vaut que DLE parce que c'est ce
qu'on voit et la réalité c'est le le
rempart ultime quoi on peut pas on peut
pas être plus intelligent que la réalité
un dos courbé et des genoux fléchis s
révélé non viable soit un être vivant
marche verticalement soit il marche sur
quatre jambes une forme de se sitent une
forme d'essentialiste bien de chez
nous leses interméires nécessair ne
peuventre actuell dans le animal ni être
mise en évidence dans des pièces
fossiles sous forme pétrifié si
seulement si seulement il existait un
animal genre un kangourou qui est
capable de se balader sur deux et quatre
pattes si seulement il existait des
animaux comme les lémuriens les makikata
qui se passent sur deux et qure pattes
si seulement il existait des ours qui
sont capables de se déplacer sur deux et
quatre pattes mais oui bien sûr s dans
la vie on ne peut se déplacer que sur
deux ou sur quatre pattes il existe pas
d'animaux qui sont capables de faire les
deux jamais jamais jamais contrairement
à la théorie de l'évolution on pense
plutôt que d'ancien bipè passe à la
locomotion quadrupède s'ils y sont
contraints par des circonstances
extérieures vit dans les arbres dans les
maricages sans doute aussi dans les
montagnes escarpées la thèse présentée
dans l'erreur de Darwin disant que
l'homme a toujours marcher verticalement
et que ses ancêtres ne peuvent pas avoir
vécu dans des arbres pour des raisons
anatomiques statiques et logiques entre
temps été soutenu l'homo sapiens
toutefois n'est pas plus devenu un
spécialiste de l'appréhension la théorie
selon laquelle nous nous distinguerions
des primates parce que nous disposons
d'une main créative permettant la
manipulation fine est contredite par
nigur qui signale que les mains des
singes anthropoïdes sont adaptés à leurs
besoins très spéciaux les mains des
singes anthropoïdes sont bien plus
modernes que celles des humains alors ça
effectivement ça a été sorti pour une
fois il dit pas des conneries ça au
moins c'est c'est vrai que normalement
enfin c'est vrai que on est toujours
parti du principe que du coup les mains
des des des singes étaient d'un les
mains primitives donc avec un pouce très
court et des doigts très longs et que
c'est c'était Nomain à nous qui était
dérivé pour qui s'était adapté à la
préhension de précision et qu' y a des
articles récents qui ont effectivement
contredit ça donc ce sont en fait les
mains des des chimpanzés et des Goris
qui sont très très dérivé adapté à la à
la préhension des branches donc à la
braquation et qu'en fait nos mains à
nous aurait des proportions qui sont
plus proches des proportions ancestrales
par contre ça veut pas dire identique il
y a quand même des carrières tout
entières qui ont été faites sur l'étude
de cette precision grip de cette
préhention en puissance et en précision
et donc il y a des muscles notamment qui
sont devenus plus gros et qui ont laissé
des traces d'insertion plus fortes sur
nos nos doigts et ça ça se voit donc
plus proche des proportions ancestrales
ça veut pas dire identique en revanche
la main de l'homme est comparativement
primitive c'est surtout notre cerveau
qui fait la supériorité de la main
humaine la recherche actuelle montre
donc qu'il n'y a pas eu de
spécialisation sous forme d'un
développement de ces extrémité
conditionné par la fonctionnalité
l'abipédie spécialement n'est pas un
avantage évolutif on notera d'ailleurs
le Cherry picking hein c'estàd que pour
une fois il nous sort une information
vraie et à peu près nouvelle mais bon il
a choisi celle qui l'a rangé on va pas
parler de tout ce qui a changé entre les
chimpanzés et les êtres humains je veux
dire on va juste parler de celle qui
marrant an ad de façon idéale n pas
fondé sur le développement évolutif du
squelette mais dans l'intervention de
l'intelligence qui contrôle le corps
d'un homme polyvalent et ne donne à
celui-ci que l'apparence d'un
spécialiste
supérieurant
prend Luc Lucy découvert en 1974
squelette à 40 % complet qui a depuis
été largement qui a depuis été largement
surclassé par Little foot découvert en
1998 rendu public en 2015 donc encore
une fois aucune [__] d'excuse et qui
est à 90 % complet et 400000 ans plus
vieux que
Lucy donc encore une fois on va nous
sortir des grands discours sur Lucy
pourquoi qui est pas bien pourquoi
qu'elle est pas gentille pourquoi que
pourquoi que c'est pas parce qu'on on a
étudié les petits fragments de Lucy que
on sait plus l'évolution humaine non ce
qu'on sait de Lucy maintenant c'est
largement surclassé parce qu'on a appris
grâce à Little foot donc encore une fois
on va nous sortir un chapitre tout
entier sur une icône de l'évolution mais
qui n'a plus désormais cette place
d'icône on va nous sortir des
informations qui sont complètement
périmées espèce de singe
australopythecus àaron 6 qui est censé
avoir vécu il y a 3,6 million d'années
l'affirmation selon laquelle Lucy
marchait verticalement est en fait un
point de vue que les paléoanthropologues
comme Richard lecky et Donald Johanson
ont défendu depuis des décennies dans
l'médiia les australopythéiens dotés
d'une tête de singe possèdent
prétendument quelques adaptations à la
marche du PED en particulier au niveau
du bin des extrémités inférieurs c'est
pourquoi les australopythéiens sont
considérés comme le stade intermédiaire
entre les singes entre Boï et l'homme en
fait le centre de gravité de Luc ne se
situe pas comme chez nous entre les
hanches mais placé plus haut et plus en
avant ce qui rend la marche encore plus
difficile qu'elle ne l'ai par ailleurs
plusieurs chercheurs ont examiné dans
des études abondantes les structures du
scelette des australopitéiens lors de sa
lckerman et le professeur Charles Oxnard
deux anatomistes des États-Unis et
d'Angleterre connus dans le monde entier
ont mené des travaux de recherche
approfondis sur différents exemplaires
d'australopit qui ont montré que cette
créature ne pouvait pas marcher en se
tenant verticalement à la manière des
hommes mais le plus frappant est
qu'après 15 ans d'études d'haement
fossiles zerman et son équip en sont
venus à la conclusion que
l'australopitethèque est une espèce de
singe et ne pouvait définitivement pas
être considéré comme pipè d'une manière
concordante Charles oxnar a rangé la
structure Ress de l'australopitthek dans
la donc alors deux choses en l'essence
ce qu'il nous dit c'est que
l'australopythèque est cert bipède
puisqu'il l'a dit il a des adaptations à
la bipédie donc il a dit il a des
adaptations à la bipédie mais ses
adaptations sont loin d'être parfaites
tu veux dire que l'australopit
se comporte tout se passe comme si
l'australopythèc était une espèce
intermédiaire entre un singe quadrupède
et un
[Rires]
hbipède donc voilà il vient de nous il
vient de nous expliquer pourquoi luciy
est considéré comme un intermédiaire
entre les singe entre le singe et
l'homme donc merci et deuxièmement donc
là il est en train de nous dire il est
en train de nous parler donc ces
dernières années d'autres espèces dominé
dominidé ayant vécu à la même période
ont été découvertes mais mettant à mal
la théorie indiquant que
l'australopytheca phenis est notre
ancêtre direct donc la raison pour
laquelle il dit que Lucy n'est pas notre
ancêtre c'est parce que on a découvert
du matos
ailleurs qui est plus proche d'être nos
ancêtres c'est exactement ce qu'il est
en train de nous montrer ici on a trouvé
du meilleur matos ailleur qui indique
que non c'était pas finalement c'était
pas luciine notre ancêtre notre ancêtre
c'est le matos qu'on a découvert
ailleurs et qui est et qui semble avoir
de de meilleur Chan d'être notre ancêtre
voil c'est ça qu'il est en train de vous
montrer donc ça ne contredit en rien la
théorie de
l'évolution sorti de contexte une fois
de
plus qu quand on a envie de lire que la
théorie de l'évolution est fausse c'est
ce qu'on lit même quand c'est pas ça
qu'on regarde c'est ça qui est fou en
fait c'est que il est vraiment il est en
train de vous sortir un
discours not il est en train de nous
sortir un discours où il vous dit en
essence exactement le contraire de ce
qu'il montre c'est exactement le
contraire de des images qu'il est en
train de vous montrer qu'il est en train
de vous raconter il est en train de vous
mettre des preuves de l'évolution il est
en train de vous dire des preuves de
l'évolution mais pour lui c'est pas des
preuves de l'évolution c'est c'est un
biais c'est même au-delà du billet de
confirmation c'est c'est il est aveugle
là il est aveugle sourd muet tout ce que
vous voulez là il ne comprend rien à ce
qu'il dit et là on est vraiment dans un
cas aigu de je comprends pas un broc de
ce que je raconte il est vraiment
là-dedans il est comme dans Hare in
Genesis c'est tellement occupé et je
pense je suis sûr qu'il a pompé toutes
ses idées dans Hare in Genesis parce que
là ça CR c'est criant c'est c'est comme
dans Hare in Genesis il est tellement
occupé par l'idée d'avoir raison qu'il
en oublie de vérifier que les
informations disent bien ce qu'il croit
que que les informations
disent Lucy est morte en tombant d'un
arbre donc elle était arboriccole ouais
ou alors elle puait la merde à vivre
dans les arbres c'est au choix scolaire
Don Johnson a modestementé que lu la
découverte la plus importante faite par
quiconque dans l'istire de toute
l'espèce humaines et les médias l'ont
présenté comme un héros il a été promu
de professeur adjoint à recevoir son
propre institut de biologie humaine à
Berkley pendant tout ce temps il n'a
jamais permis aux scientifiques
d'examiner les EAU de Lucy jusqu'en 1982
soit 8 ans plus tard depuis lors et au
fur et à mesure ouais ben un embargo de
8 ans c'est pas c'est pas extraordinaire
1988 c'était il y a 40 ans presque 40
ans
maintenant en 1982 non il a dit 1982
donc c'était il y a non il a dit 82 ou
88 je sais pas mais c'était il y a plus
de 30 ans quoi ça fait plus de 30 ans
que les gens peuvent regarder Lucy que
de plus en plus de squelettes
australopyèques ont été découvert et
examiné de nombreux évolutionnistes de
premier plan ça que semblable au champan
P modne et rien de plus ils ont
peut-être marché lég little foot little
foot d'ailleurs on peut voir
contrairement à Lucy qui n'a pas le
squelette complet little foot on peut
clairement voir les proportions des bras
et des jambes et donc les bras étaient
aussi longs que les jambes contrairement
au chapanzé qui a les bras plus longs
que les jambes et que l'humain qui a les
bras plus court plus court que les
jambes donc les australopythques comme
littlefot avaient des proportions des
bras et des jambes intermédiaire entre
l'humain et le singe étant entendu que
les singes ont des bras plus longs pour
se pendre dans les arbres et que les
êtres humains ont des jambes plus longes
que les singes parce qu'il marchent sur
leur de
pattes PL des singes pas Dr il pvit pas
parler et pass laart temps dans les
arbres à March
à en fait il essaie là il essaie de
classifier de forcer la classification
de Lucy au sein des des
singes parce que parce que parce que ils
sont essentialistes et que pour eux
c'est important
que vous rappelez vous vous rappelez
quand je vous ai dit regardez les
découvertes qui bouleverse l'évolution
humaine et ben voilà regardez la Bastos
utilis contre nous quand j'arrête pas de
vous le dire qu'à force de répéter tous
les 15 jours que les découvertes qui
bouleversse l'évolution humaine faut
arrêter faut arrêter de communiquer
comme ça à propos de la
paléanthropologie parce que c'est en
train de tuer la paléanthropologie bah
voilà la Bastos utilisé contre nous en
live la preuve elle est là
voilà donc bah maintenant il est en
train de nous dire bah Lucy c'est que un
singe mais on s'en fout de toute façon
que luciy soit que un singe puisque tu
l'as dit toi-même il y a plein d'autres
espèces qui ont été découvertes depuis
et qui forme ce ce gradiant cette chaîne
voilà les maillons de cette chaîne qui
lient les ancêtres à nous humains
moderne donc on manque pas de de ces
chaînes mais là il est il est juste en
train de s'acharner sur un des maillons
de la chaîne qui n'a tout ça pourquoi
bah parce qu'on a montré qu'il
n'appartenait pas en fait au maillon de
la chaîne donc il est il est juste en
train de s'attaquer à un maillon de la
chaîne qui ne fait même plus partie de
la
chaîne c'est lui-même qui le dit et il
s'acharne dessus comme ça en disant vous
voyez vous voyez votre enette comment il
est pour oui en ça fait long qu'on a dit
que c'était pas notre ancêtre Luc c'est
toiême toimême qui l'
raconté pourquoi tu t'achares sur ce
pvre petit maillon isolé là arrête c'est
cruel au niveau logique c'est
complètement pété ce qu'il est en train
de faire il est en train de pisser dans
un violon mais
façon un sport extrême ce
Nive
en conclusion les australopthéiens n'ont
pas de relation avec l'homme ils sont
uniquement une espèce éteinte de singe
et ne représent pas un maillon dans la
chaîne de l'homonisation en se basant
sur une analyse des canosomi circulaires
de l'oreille interne des singes et des
hommes dont la fonction est le maintien
du sens de l'équilibre des spécialistes
de l'anatomie en sont arrivés à des
résultats similaires la dimension des
canosomis circulaair de
l'australopythèque et de ses successeurs
sont très similaires à ce des singes
d'aujourd'hui même l'argument des
évolutionnistes selon lequel le
paatrimoine hédita des chimpanis en
raison dansêtre commun presque identique
à celui des hommes constiue une
propagande mensongeaire car non
seulement la statistique du squelette
mais aussi les différences dans la des
hommes et des chimpanzés sont beaucoup
plus important qu' l'admettait autre
fois c'est comme nous sommes à
monalopitciens n'ont pas de relation
avec l'homme ils sont uniquement une
espèce éteinte de singe et ne représent
pas un maillon dans la chaîne de
l'homonisation alors les
australopythèques sont-ils une espèce
éteinte sans relation non
australopythecus
aparensis Lucy n'est pas représentative
de tous les australopythèques et en
l'occurrence certains australopythèques
comme australopythecus africanus étaient
plus proche de l'être humain que ne
l'était Lucy et de même il y a des
australopythèes qui étaient plus
éloignés de l'être humain que ne l'était
Lucy comme par exemple bah little foot
voilà c'est normal parce que dans un
contexte darwinien on s'attend à avoir
des gradations comme ça dans un contexte
darwinien on s'attend à avoir des
gradations de cousins qui sont de plus
en plus proches de l'espèce de l'espèces
descendante à savoir ici Homo sapiens
c'est une conséquence encore une fois
c'est une conséquence attendue de la
théorie de
l'évolution en se basant sur une analyse
des canaux semicirculaires de l'oreille
interne des singes et des hommes don la
fonction est le maintien du sens de
l'équilibre des spécialistes de
l'anatomie on sont arrivés à des
résultats similaires la dimension des
canosomic circulaires de
l'australopitthque et de ses successeurs
sont très similaires à ce dessing
d'aujourd'hui
non non non ils ont conclu que
l'anatomie des canaux semicirculaires
racontait pas grand-chose justement
c'est c'est bien ça le problème ça a
toujours été le problème avec les canaux
semicirculaire de l'oreille interne
c'est que ça raconte pas grand-chose on
s'attendait à ce que ça raconte beaucoup
sur laabipédie en fait les canaux
semic-irculaires et il se trouve que ça
racontait pas grand-chose en réalité
donc le le signal est assez ténu et du
coup ça veut dire que les canaux SEM mis
se ressemble beaucoup en réalité qu'il
faut vraiment s'attarder sur des détails
de d'orientation de de choses comme ça
pour vraiment voir des différences donc
non même l'argument des évolutionistesqu
le patrimoineit des champ raison dans
commun presqueidti avec celui des hommes
constitue une propagande mensongère non
seulement la statistique du squelette
mais aussi les différences dans la des
hommes et des champanzés sont beaucoup
plus importantes qu'on l'admettait
autrefois donc déjà vouloir contredire
de l'ADN avec du
squelette toi tu as rien compris à la
amalogie depuis 30 ans et de deux euh
bah 90 % du génome comparable
entre l'être humain et le chimpanzé est
identique alors après si tu prends
effectivement l'ADN qui n'est pas
comparable tu vas conclure qu'il est
différent mais en réalité tu vas
comparer des trucs qui sont pas
comparables donc comparer des trucs pas
comparables si tu veux c'est comme les
les choux et les carottes hein c'est oui
tu peux toujours dire que tu peux
toujours dire que c'est pas pareil et
que du coup mais du coup comme tu
compares du rien avec du rien bah
au final ça ne veut rien dire tu tu ne
sors aucun signal en fait en comparant
des choses qui ne sont pas comparables
mais 90 % de l'ADN qui est comparable
est identique et ensuite quand tu vas au
Gori tu te rends compte qu'il y a un
pourcentage moindre et quand tu vas à
Laurent autant tu te rends compte qu'il
y a un pourcentage encore moindre et au
fur à mesure que tu t'éloignes dans la
philogénie curieusement tu te rends
compte que le pourcentage est d'autant
plus moindre et donc ça pareil c'est du
signal c'est c'est une gradation encore
une fois c'est la fameuse gradation dont
je parlais dont que la théorie de
l'évolution prévoit is c'est comme le
fameux argument de dire que nous sommes
à moitié des bananes puisque nous
partagons 50 % de notre ADN avec les
bananes la suspension du crâne encore
une fois le 50 % de l'ADN que nous
partageons avec les bananes comparable
donc c'est pour ça que ça a l'air
beaucoup c'est parce que on va comparer
que ce qui est comparable parce que
c'est ça qui va nous donner le signal
mais si on commence à comparer le pas
comparable bah oui chez les plantes
notamment il y a des copies entières de
génome qui n'existe pas chez nous ça
n'exist pas les copies entières de
génome chez les tétrapodes enfin chez
les animaux de manière générale
d'ailleurs alors que chez les plantes
vous allez avoir des génomes entiers qui
ont été complètement copiés d'ailleurs
big up à à ce qu' disait tout à l'heure
sur on crée pas de nouveau matériel
génétique quand vous avez un génô entier
qui est copié qui est dupliqué dire
c'est la création de nouveau matériel
génétique là le potentiel est infini
parce que une fois que ça aura muté tout
ce bordel ça va être ça va être une
quantité de nouveaux gènes qui vont être
absolument gigantesques donc il ignore
complètement ça il a aucune idée de ce
que ça veut dire
et encore une fois c'est l'ADN qui est
comparable parce qu'on ne peut pas
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
c'est tout donc effectivement après si
tu mesures la quantité d'ADN qui n'est
pas comparable entre une banane et un
être humain effectivement il y a une
immense quantité d'ADN qui n'est pas
comparable mais bon ça évidemment faut
s'arrêter pour le regarder ça il aurait
fallu aller voir sur Wikipédia une fois
de plus et ça aurait été ça aurait été
trop long ça aa ét vous comprenez je je
peux pas faire des vidéos putacliqu qui
vont plaire aux créationnistes et en
plus me renseigner
quoi distingue chez l'homme et le
singeune manière fondamentale et
témoigne au moins de ligé évolutif
séparé pendant une phase de passage
évolutif de la marche quadrupède à la
marche bipède la transformation de la
position du corps aurait aussi exigé des
transformations profondes de l'ensemble
du crâne les théoriciens de l'évolution
eux aussi connaissent ces différences
anatomiques mais il les ignorent on
comprend car l'absence d'explication
rationnelle des discussions qui ne
manquerit pas d'avoir lieu à propos de
leur conception ser vous rendez compte
c'est trop compliqué de passer de vous
imaginez l'adaptation à la vie bipède ça
ça aurait nécessité à ce crâne là de se
transformer de façon incroyable ouais un
peu comme ça
ouais
crivord crâe au de deomme coupit la
coltébr au crâne aurait d migrer
quasiment le long du crâne car le crâne
ch littéralement au bout de la colonne
vertébrale alors que le crâne humain est
placé sur elle cette différence
anatomique notable ne peut pas procéder
d'unard coup de la natureun des nbre et
encore une fois le hasard le hasard
alors que sélection naturelle sélection
naturel n'est pas le hasard fini point
nécessaire un redressement réussi du
sing NRE mis en évidence dans les
fossiles jusqu'à présent on a seulement
démontré la présence de l'une des deux
modalités de fixation du crâne mais
aucune qui soit située entre et
constitue un type de transition alors
que l'homme avec sa main peut saisir
d'une manière ciblée et sentir finement
le champané forme plutôt dans le
processus de
PR il y en a il y en a qui sont pas au
courant du débat qu'il y a sur la
position du foramen occipital chez
santhropus
visiblement moi je dis ça je dis rien le
trou occipital qui est là chez opus
c'est encore voilà
ah il y a des BAT il y a des BAT il y en
a qui disent que oui je suis d'accord
avec ces gens-là mais il y en a qui
disent que non pour l'instant moi je
suis d'accord avec ces gens-là bon et
puis en réalité j'ai fait une vidéo pour
dire que c'était pas si important que ça
en réalité puisque c'est pas la bipédie
la définition de l'humain la définition
de l'humain c'est l'arbre philogénétique
qu'on reconstruit à partir de tous les
caractères et pas seulement du trou
occipitale et de sa position donc j'ai
fait toute une vidéo là-dessus hein sur
la nature humaine si vous voulez je vous
mettrai la miniature là comme ça vous
pourrez et je vous la mettrai dans la
description
bref il y a débat sur la position du
foramen occipital chez
saelanthropus donc s'il y a Desbat c'est
que c'est pas si clair que ça et si
c'est pas si clair que ça bah c'est que
c'est que pas si clair que ça ça ça
ressemble quand même à on sait pas et on
sait pas ça ressemble quand même à forme
transitionnelle
ouais moi aussi je peux jouer sur les
mots pas tenir des objets entre l'index
et le pouce les singes ont la capacité
de saisir avec leurs quatre pieds et
mains de la même manière raison pour
laquelle les scientifiques vont forger à
juste titre la notion de quadreumane la
morphologie des EAU des pieds humains et
alors dire que la notion de quadreumane
est à juste tit la locomotion et non
pour se suspendre dans les arbres
comment les EAU des pieds des hommes
ont-ils pu se transformer aussi
fondamentalement qu'ils ne puissent plus
saisir avec la sélection naturelle les
arguments sont ridicule s'agitil d'un
progrès technique
de bah c'est on voit encore la cicatrice
de ce truc dans notre gros orteil hein
votre gros orteil il est encore
légèrement opposable vous pouvez
l'écarter vous avez un bien meilleur
contrôle de votre gros orteil que de vos
autres doigts enfin de vos autres
orteils du coup et et puis la raison
pour laquelle votre gros orteil est un
gros orteil bah c'est précisément parce
que autrefois il était opposable donc la
modalité de son évolution est
complètement différente de la modalité
de l'évolution de vos autres
orteils donc c'est le la présence
l'existence même de votre gros orteil
est la cicatrice évolutive du fait que
vous avez un ancêtre qui était
quadreumane comme ils disent évolution
peut-être d'une régression au sens de la
théorie de l'évolution pourquoi le pied
développé pour saisir la Ty pas été
mooifié de manière à pouvoir rendre
possible autant l'appréhension que la
marche verticale ou s'agit-il deux
caractères structurels séparés sans
aucun lien au relation de développement
ouais les les deux les deux caractères
les deux fonctions sont complètement
différentes et antagonistes c'est c'est
c'est c'est tu peux pas tu peux pas être
un coureur de fond comme l'être humain
et en même temps avoir un pouce
opposable tu vas te péter le pouce c'est
fonctionnellement ça ne marche pas tu
vas te péter le pouce auosable tout le
temps à chaque fois que tu essayes de
courir c'est tout et puis en plus il
faut une voûte pour être coureur de fond
ce que ne permet pas le la la posture
quadrumane voyez le le pied plat du
singe la voûe plantaire de l'être humain
il faut une voûte pour avoir cette
élasticité justement dans le dans le
pied qui permet la course de fond et
cette élasticité elle n'existe
absolument pas si vous êtes quadruman
donc c'est ces deux les deux conditions
sont mutuellement exclusives et c'est
pour ça qu'on peut pas avoir les deux en
même temps par contre s'il y avait un
grand designer intelligent qui était
passé par là il y aurait pas de raison
pour pour laquelle les deux conditions
seraient mutuellement seraient
mutuellement exclusives donc encore une
fois on est sur un argument magnifique
du bah en fait ça prouve que que
l'évolution est
vraie le fait que les deux situations ne
se chevauche pas comme il est en train
de le dire ça prouve que les les ça
prouve que l'évolution est vraie parce
que dans un monde parfait tel que des
tel que déterminé par un grand horloger
ça ça fonctionnerait il y aurait pas de
raison que ça fonctionne pas
le grand horloger peut tout faire et le
fait parfaitement la position des os de
la jambe des hommes et des champons
modernes ne devrait-elle pas être aussi
similaire si tous deux ont des an commun
comment on l'affirme catégoriquement des
analogies figuré des similarités in à
répondre par l'affirmatif à cette
question pourant les données parlent
nettement contre elle il est clair tout
le moins que les ancêtres des hommes ne
sont pas descendus des arbres et ne
descendent pas non plus du singe
ouancêtre commun l'ancêtre était
lui-même bip on présume que les primates
sont apparus à la fin de l'Éocène vers
Mo 55 millions à 3 milli d'années selon
la
doctr naue fa les singes sont apparus en
les primates sont
apparus au début du palaisocen voire
même au Crétacé donc dizaines de
millions d'années avant ce qui
Croo et l'HME l'HME de Tré laall
de
l'hor
plus ils ont fait des représentation
fausses oh
les dans les années 1800 ils ont fait
des représentation
fauses les différences biologiqu seltiqu
intelluelle qui existe déjà au sein de
l'espèce humaine ainsi contrairement au
idé reçu un européen est par exemple
plus proche d'un néalien que d'un
aborigène de Sv d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
le consensus scientifique qui autrefois
PLA l'omme de comme un animal ni sing ni
homme le fait qu'il maîtrisait
parfaitement le langage et disposait
d'une intelligence très similaire à
celle de l'homme actuel par exemple la
taille du Crâ montre que son cerveau é
en fait 1 % plus grand que cerveau moy
de refait de l'essentialisme cette fois
il veut nous faire croire que Néandertal
c'est un être humain à parentierlam que
la primitivité de était injustifiée qui
pouvait marcher dans la rue aujourd'hui
sans être
reconnu mais attends attendsattendss
attends c'est je veux dire la
primitivité mais intellectuelle de
Néandertal la phrase encore une fois est
sortie de son contexte il s'agit de la
primitivité intellectuelle cognitive de
Néandertal il s'agit pas de sa
primitivité morphologique sa primitivité
anatomique à Néandertal elle est
factuelle ils ont un énorme bourlet
supraorbitaire que nous Homo sapiens
avons perdu et ils n'ont pas de Menton
que nous Homo sapiens avons acquis et
l'absence de Menton est un caractère
qu'on retrouve chez les chimpanzés les
australopythèques les homoc
c'est un caractère primitif donc la
encore une fois le l'homme de Néandertal
si tu admets qu'il avait une cognition
purement humaine il avait toujours une
anatomie avec des caractères
ancestraux encore une espèce
intermédiaire Bou à 36000 ans ce qui
permet de l'intégrer parfaitement dans
la chronologie de l'évolutionnisme a été
contraint de prendre sa retraite en
disgrâce par un panel de responsables de
l'université de Francfort qui ont
déterminé qu'il avait fabriqué des
données et plagé le travail de ses
collègues au cours des 30 dernières
années le supposé expert de la datation
carbone autrefois renommé est
actuellement
complètement
mé on a trouvé un scientifique méchant
donc tous les scientifiques qui sont
méchants en
Bou si on commence à faire la liste de
tous les créationistes qui ont menti on
va pas s'en
sortir c'est c'est
ah ah ben je me disais on va on va
esquiver l'homme de P bah non évidemment
non l'homme de pown débunké par des
paléontologues débunké par des
c'est pas les créist qui onb l' de
P donc merci mes bisous l'homme de P
l'homme de pild c'était dans les années
ça a été débuné dans les années 50
déjà que le Crâ de éta en fait humain et
datait de seulement quelques centaines
d'années alors que la MAO inférieure
saillante provenait d'un récemment
décédé rus se bas uniquement sur deux
fragments d'une majoire supérieure dans
l'homme de la pristoire on affirme comme
établ sur du RO que si on dessine les D
et le palis de ramaus d'abord sur le
palais d'un puis sur celui d'un homme la
similitude avec l'homme est manifeste on
voit les choses aujourd'hui à l'inverse
les carères autrefis prétendument humain
sont censés aujourd'hui al Rama pitecus
c'était avant la découverte de Lucy
encore que Lucy justement elle elle a
changé tout ça la découverte de Lucy a
changé tout ça de beaucoup plus
d'australop
depu on a eu beaucoup de mal en fait à
faire la paix avec l'idée
que l'être humain venait d'Afrique donc
on est allé chercher ramitecus en
Asie quand bien même on avait découvert
le premier australopythèque en Afrique
en 1924 on est allé chercher ramapitcus
jusquen
Asie en espérant en fait que l'être
humain vienne pas d'Afrique et là il est
en train de N faire la même au
final
manation c'est juste des vieilles
données c'est juste vieux c'est tout
c'est vieux c'est c'est obsolè ça a été
débuné par les scientifiques sque depuis
déjà
trèsemp
grand c'est là il est en train de nous
inventer un grand complot sorti de nulle
part alors qu'il fait que nous présenter
des données obsolètes et c'est
tout j'arrête même plus la vidéo j'ai
envie de finir j'en peux plus j'en peux
plus ça fait 3h ça fait 4 He je sais
plus
là su dev commom être humain en latin on
l'a considéré comme tras d'union entre
australus et l'tique jusqu'il a peu de
temps l'OM
ier il y a même pas homonalady dans son
arbre donc il vous présente encore des
trucs qui sont qui sont pas à jour quoi
qui était déjà pas à jour il y a un an y
a 2
anus asiatique et l'omoelbergis européen
appelé autrefis Homo sapiens archaïque
qui est cé navoir été précé que par un
homoantor il existe encore entre ces
espèces quelques désignations prête à
être choisie qui sous une forme ou une
autre ont été considéré un jour
quelconque comme des désignation
standard plus viol par les spécialistes
en passant par ce que l'on appelle les
formes mixtes par exemple homme de
Steinheim et l'homme moderne précoce de
cranion l'évolution est avoir conduit
ensuite à l'homme moderne qui vit
aujourd'hui selon quelques chercheurs se
basant sur des examens de l'ADN amené
par un généticien le professeur
doctb sousespèce éteinte de l'homme
moderne homapi a quand même le prix
Nobel quoi
merde en tout cas le N un M qui a été
éliminé chaîne de l'omonisation et pour
lequel on ne dispose pas non plus de
maillon de remplacement n'importe quel
autre maillon prendra la place Deen dis
les évolutionist com il arrive comment
il arrive à dire que Néandertal a été
éliminé de la chaîne de luminisation bon
chaîne de lominisation qui n'existe pas
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure mais
comment il dit qu'il a été éliminé alors
même qu'il a dit tout à l'heure que les
Européens avaient plus d'ADN de
Néandertal que les que les Africains je
veux dire Néandertal fait partie de nous
littéralement il peut pas avoir été
exclu je il a encore une fois zéro
compréhension de ce qu'il dit je sais
même pas c'est lui qui a écrit son texte
vraiment peutêtre trouveron encore
fragment de mâchoire et déclarera-on
qu'il est la preuve d'une espèce qui
survient à la place d'une interten et
qui est censé représenter imaginalement
des millions d'individus l'ont trouvé
jusqu'à ce que après des années on
constate que c'est à nouveau une mchour
de s
oui alors dans la même logique que tout
à l'heure vous trouvez une dent est-ce
que c'est raisonnable de d'imaginer que
votre dents se baladait tout seul bah
c'est pareil quand vous trouvez un
fragment de mâchoire vous trouvez un
fragment de mâchoire les dents sont cell
d'un sont sont celles d'un
australopythèque hein vous avez des
squelettes complets d'australopythèque
comme little foot pour vous en
convaincre est-ce qu'il est raisonnable
de penser que l'individu auquel
appartenait cette mâchoire se promenait
tout seul dans la
pampa est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est ça l'hypothèse raisonnable
est-ce qu'il est normal pour vous
d'imaginer que quand vous trouvez un os
comme ça dans la nature vous trouvez un
os et vous vous vous dites cet os se
promenait tout seul et il y avait pas
d'autrees représentant de son espèce
autour de lui non non non non non non
non il était tout seul et c'est tout
c'est est-ce que pour vous c'est
raisonnable ce genre d'hypothèse pour
moi ça l'est pas du tout pour moi c'est
de la fantaisie pure et dure faut être
complètement givré pour s'imaginer que
c'est ça puisse être le cas ce n'est pas
comme ça que fonctionne la biologie la
biologie faut être au moins deux pour
faire des bébés et faut avoir des
parents et faut il faut qu'il y ait
d'autres représentants pour qu'il y ait
une suffisamment de diversité génétique
pour qu'il ait
pour qu'il y ait pas de pour qu'il y ait
pas de consanguinité donc oui quand vous
trouvez un les preuves qu'il y avait au
moins un individu qui existait
représenté par cédent ou autre chose bah
ça veut dire qu'il y avait une
population
oui
mais je je ne reviens même pas qu'on est
en 2023 et qu'il y a des gens pour qui
ce soit pas évident c'est fou vous êtes
fous je deviens fou sérieusement si la
chaîne de l'évolution a été légitimée
sous forme australopitcus auobilis Homo
sapiens cela signifie donc que chacune
de ces espèces était le précurseur de
ceux qui suivent et doivent selon les
lois de Darwin avoir existé l'un après
l'autre suivant donc l'évolution les
découvertes plus récentes deelqu il
s'apprête à faire une pirouette
c'està-dire à réutil retourner la
buissonnance de l'évolution humaine
contre les
évolutionnistes je vous annonce je vous
annonce que ça va être acrobatique parce
que ça veut rien
dire c'est c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
espèces qui ont vécu en même temps
qu'elles ont pas d'ancêtres en commun
ces espèces
donc oui encore une fois c'est c'est la
la linéarité de l'évolution humaine qui
a déjà été critiqué plein de fois qui a
résulté en la buissonance de l'évolution
humaine l'une comme l'autre sont tout à
fait compatibles avec l'évolution
humaine donc là ce qu'il est en train de
nous faire c'est c'est même pas
acrobatique c'est juste r région isolé
de cette terre les soisant ancêtr
primitif précédant l'homme moderne selon
la théorie de l'évolution de Darwin ont
toujours en vérité véc distinctement et
souvent en même temps que lui encore au
siècle dernier en 1931 onom en Afrique
des parul d'homes primitif
d'ut
aujourd'hui et Mesdames et Messieurs
c'est un cas de
racisme on a découvert au sud de
Marrakech une forme préhistorique de
type néandalienne avec front fuyant
mâchoire fuyante et arcade sourcilière
fortement proéminente il courait et
utilisait les instruments donc Mesdames
et Messieurs voici la personne qu'il
nous a représenté dans
son dans sa vidéo il s'agit de Bassou ao
Bassou un homme qui vivait en 1931 dans
une ferme près de la ville de
Marrakech et donc c'était un homme bah
qui étant donné la grosse influence
racistocolonialiste de l'époque avait
été interprété comme un être humain
primitif puisque évidemment nous sommes
en Afrique
hein au début du 20e
siècle sauf que depuis ben ça c'est ce
qu'on voit he ce profil si particulier
de Bassou on le sait c'est de la micro
donc c'est une pathologie en réalité la
microcéphalie et donc ce pauvre monsieur
on le retrouve ici tranquillement en
train d'être montré comme dans la la
belle époque de la grosse colonisation
bien sale en train de d'être interprété
comme un être humain primitif
voilàou le couronnement de cette vidéo
mesdames et messieurs on a
atteint
néolonialisme exist de ces
espècesusion par les évolutionist
représente une mise en série arbitraire
d'un pe nombre d' CR la be matérielle de
évolu de l'HME peuttre plusieurs
milliers de fossiles
homonaled à lui tout seul 1500 fossiles
en 2015 on en a découvert plus depuis
l'homme de Néandertal plusieurs
centaines de milliers on a certainement
pour l'homme de néandal on a plusieurs
dizaines d'individus complets pour
australopitecus SBA on a de deux
individus quasiment complets pour
aarensis on a au moins trois ou quatre
individus complets pour homoerectus on a
pareil plus au moins qu ou C individus
complets non ça on a plusieurs milliers
de fossiles et des dizaines et des
dizaines d'individus complets on n pas
quelques fossiles générations stendant
sur environ 4 millions d'années le
développement débutant à
l'australopthecus à phensis et allant
jusqu'au nétalien se réduit uniquement à
300 fragmentos qui ne peuvent être
attribués moins de 50 hommes ce qui
implique que pour peut-être 3000
générations on ne dispose que d'une
seule découverte d' le plus souvent
fragmentaireomme pour peut-être 250000
générations Cendant sur environ 4
millions d'années le développement
débutant à l'australopcus à phensis et
all jusquau nalien se réduit uniquement
à 300 fragments d'os qui ne peuvent être
attribués qu'à moins de 50 h ce qui
implique que pour peut-être ah ouais il
est vraiment pas à jour he 300 fragments
d'os je sais pas où il a trouvé ce
chiffre 300 fragment do mais non comment
peuton quand un créationniste me dit
qu'on a pas d'espèce
intermédiaire
c'est comme je le disais homonalady
depuis 2015 on a en 2015 on avait déjà
faossile comment en 2022 il est arrivé à
300 fragments d'ose je sais pas pour
tout depuis 4 millions d'années je veux
dire pas seulement au Monal pour tout
depuis 4 je sais
pas cérébral beaucoup plus important
parî TR grande et comme on ne documente
aucun processus de développement g
évolution lente une forme de transition
est devenu nécessaire l'his devait de ce
fait nécessairement être propagé en tant
que bouchetrou permettant de rendre
crédible la théorie de l'évolution
quelques scientifiques parmi eux Wilfred
le gros Clark remettent pourtant en
question l'existence de la forme de
transition
quomag raison de découvertes inexactes
et devrait être à nouveau é s toutes ses
formes et Robinson affir même ouais mais
encore une fois là on parle juste de
c'est comme pour les dinosaures tout à
l'heure on parle juste de synonymie de
taxon en réalité donc eux ce qu'il
propos c'est de ce qui a été proposé
c'est que étant donné la variabilité
morphologique qu'on voit chez les les ce
qu'on appelait autrefois homogéorgicus
c'est-à-dire les fossiles découverts en
geéorgie
admanici il y aurait la possibilité que
certains des hininés qu'on a découvert
et qui avaient un petit volume crâen
puissent appartenir tous à homoererectus
mais dans ce cas-là on aurait juste
homoererectus mais ça veut pas dire
qu'encore une fois les fossiles qu'on a
découvert qui appartiennent à homoabilis
n'existe pas ça veut pas dire que des
hominidés avec différentes tailles de
cerveau je veux dire au lieu d'avoir une
transition vous aurez petit cerveau
moyen cerveau gros cerveau bah vous
aurez une évolution qui passera par
petit cerveau petit moyen et gros
cerveau et Gros Cerveau donc en fait ça
change juste l'état de la transition
mais ça ne change en aucun cas l'idée
qu'il y a une transition c'est juste que
au lieu de passer de blanc gris noir bah
on passe de blanc damier
noir voilà c'est tout c'est au lieu
d'avoir un mélange de gris et de de de
blanc et de noir qui fassent du gris ben
on a un mélange avec certains individus
qui sont en avec l'état primitif et
certains individus qui sont en état
dérivé mais quoi qu'il arrive ça change
rien au fait qu'on ait une transition
que c découvertes correspondait à un
mélange faux de parties de squelette de
l'australopythecus donc de singe et de
l'homoerectus de l'homme le cas de
l'uréapiticus démontre de façonante
qu'une locomotion sur de jambes
n'implique pas nécessairement une place
parmi les ancêtres de W
on on va donc la pêche àoropus pour nous
dire que la bipéie existe indépendamment
des humains oui mais ça on le sait
depuis depuis qu'on connait Laurent
Laurent c'est un bip d'arboricole comme
l'uréopcus donc du coup il admet l'idée
d'une d'une apparition multiple de
laabipédie
et ça c'est pareil c'est complètement
contraire à un dessin intelligent c'est
complètement contraire à une création
intelligente dont il a repris les
arguments jusqu'à présent point par
point j'ai envie de dire
euh un dessin intelligent ne fait pas
apparaître deux fois la même chose un
dessin intelligent il fait la il fait la
chose une fois et il la refait pas c'est
le faire faire s'y reprendre à plusieurs
fois pour faire la même chose c'est le
contraire d' d'une conception
intelligente c'est une conception
stupide sur terre et de l'apparition de
l'homme pas tenableette dernière
for c'est la conclusion avec un peu de
chance il va pas répéter de
conneries y est il va enfin nous dire de
quel J il appartient à il appent à
lui partelle des
farftion
c'est donc un créationniste pur c'est
pas seulement un antiévolutionniste
neutre entre
guillemets voilà l'évolution nexiste pas
donc Dieu existe non c'est faux le
raisonnement est complètement
faux c'est pas parce que tu as prouvé
même si tu avais réussi à prouver que
l'évolution n'existe pas ça prouve
toujours pas l'exist d'un grand
créateur ement transmettre à travers
cette vidéo serait de simplement vous
inciter à vous balader en forêt venez
observer la forme des arbres la
complexité de leur racin la géométrie de
leur feuilles amusez-vous de la coque
d'un escargot des galeries d'une
fourmière ou de la beauté d'un papillon
personnellement je n'y vois ni hasard ni
chos mais le résultat d'une intelligence
partout si vous regardez aussi la
complexité d'un la complexité d'un
éclair quand il y a de l'orage B vous y
verrez qu'en fait c'est complètement
aléatoir voilà la preuve de l'existence
d'une force de vie qui est imprignée
d'un consci
ta guule c'est
mag toi aussi deviens un grand adepte de
ma secte le ta gueule c'est
magique tu as demandé l'autorisation à
ces gens pour les
[Musique]
filmer la vie c'est magique donc la
grande conclusion de cette heure de
torture que je viens de m'affliger et de
ces 4 heures que vous venez de mangez
vous c'est ta gueule c'est magique et le
ta gueule c'est magique c'est religion
et ben c'était pas ouf et ben c'était
vraiment pas ouf et vraiment je ne
félicite mais alors absolument pas les
gens qui m'ont envoyé ça en me disant
qu'il y avait des bons arguments dans
cette vidéo et surtout pas des arguments
nouveaux donc voilà je je vous aie je
vous déteste je me déteste je déteste le
monde entier c'est l'effet que me fait
cette
vidéo voilà mais non je vous aime je
vous fais ah par pitié vite playback
très vite très très vite je termine je
j'ai dit que je finirai je finirai voilà
vas-y
allez donc c'était des Bage et pénitence
je vous remercie de l'avoir suivi je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne c'est bon quand ça
s'arrête